6,7,9,5,4,5,6,7,8,9.
Die nächste Folge kommt gleich.
188.
Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 188. Ich hab dein Mikrofon noch nicht auf, willst du das selber machen?
Mach schon, mach mich auf.
Ein 0, jetzt war nicht so hier. Ich wollte doch jetzt das irgendwie so...
Wo hast du ihn nahezu...
Quasi professionell hier einführen. Jetzt hast du es wieder kaputt gemacht. Dann mach ich jetzt mal das Musikbett an. Herzlich willkommen zum Chaosradio 188 mit mir im Studio. Also ich bin Holger Klein, ich hab keine Ahnung. Darum sitzen hier Leute, die Ahnung haben. Einer davon ist der Erdgeist. Hallo, Erdgeist.
Wunderschönen guten Abend.
Das andere ist der Mirko. Hallo. Warum ist mein Mikrofon? Ah, weil ich es nicht eingeschaltet habe. Das andere ist der Mirko. Ja, hallo. Hallo. Und der Nibbler. Long time no see. Worum geht's denn heute, Erdgeist?
Geht heute um Plastirouter.
Plastirouter? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Plastirouter und einem...
Kohlenstoffrouter?
eigentlich nur so ein Überbegriff für das, was man inzwischen so von Flower Power Enterprises aus China in sein Wohnzimmer gestellt bekommt, damit es einem Internet macht. Das ist meistens aus Plaste.
Also das Ding, was ich mir neulich zugelegt habe, also ich hab mir neulich eine Fritzbox besorgt.
Ja, du arbeitest ja auch hier, wa?
Ja, jetzt hab ich, ich bin das Problems, ich hab das angeschlossen und das Ding, es wird so heiß immer. Und jetzt hab ich Angst.
Ach so, du hast die gleich Nahrungsmittel-Edition.
Es geht um Router. Können wir den überhaupt gibt's da genug zu erzählen für zwei Stunden?
Ich bin da auch nicht, keine Ahnung. Wir setzen uns hier mal erstmal hin und gucken mal. Aber vielleicht stellst du noch die anderen Gäste vor, es ist voll unheilig.
Ach, die anderen Gäste. Hallo Mirko. Hallo. Es funktioniert diesmal. Mirko, was qualifiziert dich denn wohl hier über Router-Stellungen zu Unterstellungen? Vermutlich nüscht. vielleicht hat ja der Nibbler Ahnung.
Was wie, wovon? Router? Was ist das Thema heute eigentlich?
Musst du mal Erdgeist fragen.
Kann man jemand schon in der Wikipedia nachgucken, was Router überhaupt heißt? Nicht das...
Ja, also ich kenn ja einen, der sagt immer Router.
Wer was?
Der sagt halt immer Router, wenn er Router nimmt. Dann sag ich immer Affe! Funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Aha, aber hast du ihn noch nicht konditioniert bis jetzt?
Nee, der lässt sich nicht konditionieren.
Ach, ich kann das nicht mal aussprechen. Dieses Internetradio, man macht.
Das gibt auch keine Zukunft dieser Scheiße. Wo fangen wir denn eigentlich an mit Routern? Gab es sowas schon, bevor es WLAN gab?
Also das war ganz früher, da hatte man sich zu Hause auch so eine Box in sein Zuhause gestellt, um Internet zu haben, aber das war damals noch ganz anders. Das war die Zeit, wo... Kannst du dich mal in den Spruch erinnern?
Box Zuhause Internet Modem.
Genau. So Junge, hier ist ein Internet, der Papa will telefonieren.
Genau. Den besten, den ich je erlebt habe, war das erste Mal, dass ich Pizza übers Internet bestellt habe, haben wir dann irgendwie nach zweieinhalb Stunden angerufen und gesagt, hier, äh, wir haben eben auf eurer Webseite Pizza bestellt, aber habt ihr uns vergessen oder ist das kaputt? Und dann sagten die allen anders, ja ne, wir haben versucht anzurufen, um das zu verifizieren. Aber da war immer besetzt.
Ja, das war ja, wenn die bei uns dann angerufen haben, meine Eltern hatten da irgendwie so, zwar analoges Telefon, aber irgendwie so moderner Scheiß, der dann immer machte, wenn jemand angerufen hat, dann hat es immer in der Leitung gemacht, was immer im Modem durcheinander gebracht hatte und dann war wie die Verbindung kaputt. Wie hießt ihr das, dieses Feature Nübler?
Anklopfen.
Anklopfen, irgendeine Frage.
War Teil des Produkts Anis. Analogenetzwerk, diese Dinge im integrierten Service hast du nicht gesehen. Also sozusagen so was wie ISDN-Features für Analog-Telefone sowie mehrere Leitungen hin und her makeln und so weiter. Und das ist für so eine Modemübertragung echt ungut, wenn da so mit 440 Hertz düt, düt zwischengepiept wird, weil da gehen dann Daten kaputt und wenn genügend Daten kaputt gehen in der Verbindung, dann macht das Modem halt klick.
Ja stimmt, ich erinnere mich. Und ich hab das nicht verstanden, warum das immer kaputt geht. Also ich hab eben gedacht, ja Modem kaputt. Ja klar, dann bin ich dann mal telefoniert, aber das war dann auch kaputt.
War da dein erstes Modem aus Plaste?
Mein erstes Modem war aus Stahl. Oder irgendwie sowas. Was war denn da auch ein? Das war ein Kraftmodem. Das war ein Highscreen Modem mit 14.400, was hatte das?
Fünfstellig, ja. Das ist immer so Schmanzlängenvergleiche.
Du armes Schwein.
Nee, nee, ich war noch dreistellig.
Wow, nee, das nicht. So ein Akustikkoppler hatte ein Freund von mir, aber da dachte ich, das ist jetzt heftig.
Ich wollte schon fragen, ob dein Modem dann auch ein Posthörnchen drauf hat, also ein FTZ-Siegel. Das war damals noch nach der Zeit. Das war von Highscreen.
Nee, damals waren die noch mit FTZ-Siegel, oder?
Du hattest dann aber zumindest schon was, was du da anschließen durftest. Na ja, weil das war ja lange Zeit, war es ja auch total verboten, da irgendwas anzuschließen.
Nee, da hab ich noch Mofas frisiert, als das so war.
Die Strafen waren da schon echt drastisch. Das war ja eigentlich auch der Gründe, warum der Chaos Computer Club damals gegründet wurde, weil da, was war das, schon fünf Jahre darauf, ein nicht zugelassenes Modem an seine Telefonleitung anzuschließen?
Hätten die es überhaupt damals merken können, dass man ein nicht zugelassenes Modem angeschlossen hat?
Ja, das haben sie gemerkt, in dem ihnen ein Vermittlungszentrum abgebrannt ist. Ob sie die ein bisschen... Wie jetzt? Weil das war irgendwie auch selber zusammengelötet oder so.
Das Vermittlungszentrum war selber zusammengelötet?
Nein, das war dann das Modem. Das auch. Wahrscheinlich auch. Aber das war dann das Modem, was jemand selber zusammengelötet hat. Da hat er dann wieder so einen fiesen Kurzen gemacht, was dazu führte, dass es einen Kabelbrand in der Vermittlungsstelle gab.
Aber wie hat denn das Modem, was der Typ zu Hause stehen hatte, in der Vermittlungsstelle einen Kurzen gemacht?
Das geht schon.
Das geht?
Ja, da gehen normalerweise 40 Volt irgendwie bis zum...
Das reicht?
Na, normalerweise gehen das 40 Volt. Wenn du da irgendwie was falsch machst und dann die 220 Volt Wechsel drauflegst, dann kannst du da schon Eindruck hinterlassen bei der Gerätschaft, die da im Rechenzentrum ist.
Okay, aber wenn denen jetzt nicht das Ding abgebrannt wäre, hätten die das je gemerkt, dass da irgendjemand irgendwas angeklemmt hat, was da nicht dran darf? Also, weil da kommen doch fünfstellig Baut durch. Das schickt doch nicht irgendeine Kennung mit. Hey, guck mal, eine FTZ-Zulassung.
Wahrscheinlich war jetzt die Anzahl der Leute, die da solche Boxen zu Hause stehen gehabt haben, die lizenziert sind, auch sehr übersichtlich. Wenn du jetzt der eine der Postlerzahlen regionen bist, an denen sie so ein Ding nicht verkauft haben, dann haben sie wahrscheinlich auch gewusst das.
Stimmt, die haben die ja selber verkauft auch alle.
Du durftest doch dotieren. Aber sowas hat sich ja über die ganze Zeit durchgezogen, dass Router heute so selbstverständlich, dass dein gesamtes Zuhauseinternet von einer Plastabox gemacht wird, wo sämtliche kleinen Gerätschaften, großen Computer über diesen einen Internetanschluss raus dürfen. Das war ja bis vor 5 Jahren überhaupt noch nicht gang und gäbe. Da durftest du genau ein Gerät eigentlich anschließen, wenn du einen Telekom-Anschluss hattest. Da kam ja wirklich ein analoges Signal raus, was an deinem Computer terminiert. Das hat dir dann Internet gemacht. Dann konntest du AOL klicken.
Das ist aber länger her als 5 Jahre. Ich hab neulich festgestellt, AOL gibt's noch. Das fand ich total abgefahren. Es gibt noch AOL. Ich kenn sogar jemand mit einer AOL-E-Mail-Adresse. Ich find das sehr lustig.
Oh Gott, macht der das irgendwie so ironisch oder?
Nee, nee, nee. Ist kein Hipster.
Was ist das eigentlich, was wir da grad hören?
Das ist auch wieder aus meiner Lieblingsmusikquelle. Es ist eine Webseite mixotic.net heißt die und da gibt es halt lauter so Creative Commons Mixed Apes. Und ich finde das so schön, das kann man so schön drunter legen und einfach wegplätschern lassen. Und hinterher scherzt keinen, wenn man es von wegen so, weißt du, ein Gamer und ein Driss hier. Ja und das ist Modern Klassiks mit Ques Klassiks. Modern Klassiks von DJ Kirill Sergeyev.
Das ist schön, gefällt mir.
Der Nibbler ist eher am SMS am Schreiben.
Handy aus!
Ich glaube, der recherchiert noch heimlich. Dabei habe ich ihm das Thema vorher gesagt.
Ich informiere mich gerade, was in solchen Routern alles drin ist. Alles mögliche an Zeug und Gedöns und überhaupt. Die machen wir mit Telefon und Internet und Hausautomation.
Du meinst, es ist nicht schlimm, dass das Ding so heiß wird bei mir?
Nee, das muss ja auch... Vielleicht rechnet das auch einfach für andere Leute Bitcoins.
Das ist Teil eines der größten Botnetze, welches aus Routern besteht.
Wie? Was?
Was? Wir haben ja einen Ankündigungstext auch geschrieben, das ist größte zusammenhängend vernetzte Landliebewiesen.
Aber wieso sollte denn jetzt meine... Warum sollte meine Fritzbox denn jetzt Bitcoins rechnen?
Na was soll's sonst mit den CPU-Cycles machen? Ich meine, du hast da einen echt amtlich satten Prozessor drinstecken. Wär doch schade, wenn der sich nur langweilt, oder?
Ja, aber wär's denn dann nicht wenigstens sinnvoll, das Ding würde für mich Bitcoins rechnen?
Ja, warum machst du das nicht? Warum lässt jemand anders drauf...
Ja, weil ich keinen Plan von dem ganzen Scheiß hab und einfach nur das eingeschaltet hab und dann ist das heiß geworden und jetzt steht das da und immer wenn ich nach Hause komme, hab ich so Angst, dass meine Wohnung abgebrannt... Entschuldigung, ich habe zu wenig Sachverstand.
Du kannst da andererseits einfach mal einen Schraubendreher nehmen und einen aufschrauben, gucken, ob irgendwelche von den Bauelementen da drin so die Bräuchlern schon nach oben gestreckt haben. Dann fiept es meistens noch so hochtönig und dann wird es auch immer ganz hässlich warm.
Nee, das macht es nicht. Das Ding ist halt einfach nur echt warm. Und das hab ich nie so verstanden. Zurück in die Vergangenheit. Es ist ja jetzt hier keine Therapie, obwohl...
Hört sich so an wie die Leute, die anrufen und dann erzählen, dass ihr ihr Plastorouter kaputtest.
Also wir sind hier nicht die Hotline, doch. Ruft an, wenn ihr Probleme mit euren Routern habt.
Oh nein.
Der Nibbler löst euch die. Der kennt sich aus. 0331 70971, jetzt soll es unsere Nummer. Und wer eine Frage hat, weil zum Beispiel vielleicht das Internet nicht geht, wir haben hier Experten sitzen.
Die Entwicklung ging ja dann irgendwann so weiter, dass man...
Es ruft einer an.
Dann berat ich ihn doch mal.
Ja, mach ich gleich.
Okay, die Entwicklung ging ja dann so weiter, dass irgendwann es einfach nicht mehr ausgereicht hatte, so einen Rechner rumstehen zu haben. Da hat man auch in allen computernischen Netzwerkkarten gehabt, hat sich dann so einen Hub hingestellt und dieser Hub hat dann, ja, so galvanisch diese Rechner untereinander verbunden und die haben dann meistens, konnte dann einer von diesen Rechnern, konnte dann Pakete weiterleiten. Der hat sich dann so nach draußen als nur ein Rechner verkleidet, aber alle Pakete, die da ans Internet geschickt werden sollten, dann als komm von mir ausgegeben und alle Pakete, die aus dem Internet wieder zurückkamen, nachgeguckt, wo sie denn wieder hinmusten. Das war damals echt der heiße Scheiß. Als ich das erste Mal im Club aufgeschlagen bin, da hatten die damals Masquerading gehabt, wo sie dann irgendwie auch noch so einen komischen IP-Adressenbereich genommen haben, der eigentlich ganz woanders vergeben ist, aber der war so cool, wenn man 23 23 23 und dann noch so ein Octet, was man sich aussuchen konnte.
Aber stimmt, war das damals nicht auch irgendwas Verbotenes, so zu tun, als hätte man nur ein Gerät im Netzwerk hängen?
Ja, genau.
Das war ja auch nicht erlaubt. Wie ist denn das noch?
Telekom halt.
Nein, das andere. Wie hieß das, was man gemacht hat, um das zu verschleiern? Ich überleg die ganze Zeit.
Das war Masquerading oder?
NAT.
Ja.
Das ist ja der aktuelle Kampfbegriff dafür.
Ach so, der aktuelle Kampfbegriff.
Na, der ganz aktuelle Kampfbegriff.
Ist das etwa immer noch verboten?
Aber das wandert jetzt weiter Richtung Netz. Also da die IP-Adressen knapp werden, wird diese Technik jetzt in, also weit vor dem Router zu Hause angewendet und man kriegt auf dem Router selbst schon nur noch eine private Adresse. Und weil das sonst nicht so cool ist, wenn man sagt, ja, wir machen jetzt Nat bei uns, sagt man, wir machen eine Carrier-Grade-Nat. Das ist dann so eine Pro-Kart-Leiste und auf Preis.
Aber letztendlich ist es einfach nur das, was ich die ganzen Jahre schon mache zu Hause.
Ja, aber halb mit dem Unterschied, dass du halt zu Hause wirklich keine richtige IP-Adresse mehr bekommst und da dürfen wir noch gespannt sein, für was für Probleme das sorgen wird, weil ja, das ist ein weiterer Schritt Richtung Entmündigung des Teilnehmers. Du bist halt kein gleichberechtigter Teilnehmer mehr, der Internetverbindungen aufbauen kann, so Paketverbindungen zu anderen IPs, sondern du bist so ein Teilnehmer hinter einem Router, der diese Adressumsetzung macht, der bei deinem ISP steht und nicht mehr bei dir zu Hause.
Ich denke, das Mittel gegen knappe Adressen ist IPv6. Also du stand in der Zeitung.
Da versteht doch keiner.
Ich hab das Internet gelesen. Warum machen wir nicht einfach IPv6 statt zum Scheiß?
Die ganzen Provider sind noch nicht so weit mit ihrer Backendinfrastruktur. Das wird alles derzeit noch umgestellt. Das sollte schon vor einiger Zeit etabliert werden.
Das Protokoll ist jetzt zwölf Jahre alt, aber mittlerweile hat man sich dann doch mal überlegt, dass man das mal jetzt so weit einführen sollte.
Und dann machen die wahrscheinlich trotzdem die Nummer mit den privaten IP-Adressen, ne?
Nein.
Parallel, weil das jetzt beschlossen ist.
Das ist halt schwierig. Du kannst ja nicht verkaufen. Ich meine, was hast du irgendwie von IPv6, was du deinem Endkunden eine große annoncieren kannst?
Versteht doch eh keiner.
Genau.
Wenn du zu einem ganz normalen User kommst und sagst, hier jetzt auch mit dem modernen IPv6.
IPv6 ist für die meisten User einfach, ja bestimmt Internet, so hätten wir jetzt heute nicht mehr.
Das Tolle an diesem Natt ist ja auch, dass er als Feature verkauft wird, dass es eine Firewall ist. Das heißt, die einzige öffentliche IP-Adresse derzeit bei IPv4 ist ja die deines Routers. Und alle Rechner dahinter, die sind von dem Internet von außen nicht erreichbar. Und bei IPv6 ändert sich das auch nochmal, weil da hat dann jeder Rechner hinter deinem Router eine öffentliche IP-Adresse. Und das wird auch nochmal sehr spaßig, weil es sehr viele Geräte gibt, die halt nicht nur, also wie beim Router jetzt eine veraltete Firmware haben. Da können wir auch nochmal was zu sagen, denke ich. Kühlschränke, Fernseher, was verschiedene.
All das, wo du eigentlich überhaupt keine Security-Gedanken dir gemacht hast.
Oder was dich irgendwie nachrichtigt, wenn ich aus deinem IPv6-Kühlschrank raus und sage, es ist eine neue Firmware verfügbar.
Weil ist ja alles im privaten Laden und das ist ja von Haus aus sicher. Da kommt ja keiner ran von außen.
Auch eine Weile gedauert damals, bis die Leute begriffen haben, dass dieses WLAN, oh, hätten wir vielleicht einführen sollen, dass dann irgendwann die Entwicklung weiter Richtung WLAN ging. Das war auch irgendwie einer der erhebenden Momente damals, als ich das erste Mal mit so einem kleinen Handheld, PDAs hießen sie damals, da gab es so irgendwie einen von Compact, gibt's Compact noch?
Weiß ich gar nicht, aber es gab einen von Compact, genau, das war dann auch mit so einem...
So ein IPAC hieß das Ding.
Genau, IPAC, aber der hatte kein WLAN, sondern da musste man noch eine Karte reinstecken.
Da musste man dann so einen Jack reintun, so eine extra große Plastetasche, wo man hinten dann so eine PCMCIA-Karte reinstecken konnte.
Na, ich hatte schon etwas moderneres Ding, da konnte man die PCMCIA, aber das war so eine kleine, konnte man direkt ins Gerät stecken.
Wir sollten den Hörern vielleicht kurz sagen, was PCMCIA heißt.
Aber das war dann, als ich da das erste Mal im Hof des Clubs stand und dann dieses Ding da Karte reingesteckt plötzlich, da war nur ein Windows-Mobile drauf, war irgendwie echt umständlich, irgendwie in eine Webseite abrufen und plötzlich war irgendwie, ich steh hier mitten draußen im kalten Hub, irgendwie das Internet in meiner Hand und es geht, das war so der Star Trek Moment, wo ich dann wusste, jetzt ist wirklich 1998.
Ich wollt grad sagen, wann war das? Erinnert sich noch?
Ja, 1998.
Hattest du keinen Schlüssel für den Club, dass du auf dem Hof sein musstest?
Nee, das war schon die, ich wollte da extra raus, ich wollte noch, ich wollte das mal probieren, weil ging ja, ich hab mir über alles zusammengeschnaut und dann war irgendwie drin auch so, da stand dann drin, stand so ein Router, so ein ganz, da waren die ganzen Mac-Fraktionen im Club heute dann schon ganz früh angefangen, so diese teuren Router, die damals von Apple, diese Base Stations, diese UFOs da. War aber auch richtig plaste. Ja, und ging irgendwie. Und das dann zusammen war irgendwie, war schön das erste Mal. Aber dann hab ich dann auch gleich gemerkt, ey, du stehst grad draußen und drinnen haben sie Internet gemacht. Die meisten Leute glauben aber, dass so ihr Netz wahrscheinlich auch mit der Haustür aufhört. Und das war dann damals so eins meiner großen Momente, für die ich mich heute noch in den Arsch treten kann, da so ich, kleiner stolzer Hacker, das ist das erste Mal, als ich dieses Funknetzwerk erkundet hatte, die Gegend laufen überall, waren so die noch damals spärlich verteilten WLANs verteilt in der Gegend. Und hab dann mal geguckt, oh geil, Anwaltskanzlei, oh geil, Krankenhaus. Krankenhaus.
Wir hatten auch mal ein Chaosradio, ne? Da seid ihr mal rumgefahren, habt mal ein bisschen geguckt, was man so aufhaken kann. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie lang das ist.
Das ist viel zu lange her, aber dass du dich dran erinnerst, ist schon geil.
Ich fand das sehr bemerkenswert. Was war das? Irgendeine Privatklinik in Mitte? Die im Grunde hätten sie auch ihre Akten einfach draußen lagern können.
Ja, aber da hat uns unser Anwalt empfohlen, das nicht zu erzählen, wie die heißt. Aber so viele gibt es auf der Friedrichstraße auch nicht. Das war dann lustig, die kommen ja immer alle mit Kennung. Diese Geräte, die da auch rumstehen, die sieht man dann in diesem Netz auch. Die hatten dann noch so ein Netbios-Namen, da konnte man dann sozusagen so ein Windows-Protokoll, da konnte man dann die Geräte fragen, wie sie dann heißen. Da waren das die ganzen Rechner, die dann in Patiententischen standen und da glaube ich auch ein bisschen die Medikation kontrolliert haben.
Oder der Rezeptdrucker.
Da habe ich mich dann ganz spontan nicht so gut gefühlt, aber dann hat der Spiegelredakteur, der es mit uns gemacht hat, der hat dann den Schwanz eingekliffen, sich nicht getraut und die juristische Abteilung hat es auch nicht so richtig verstanden. Aber auf jeden Fall war dann ganz plötzlich die riesengroße Oh mein Gott, alle haben WLAN, das ist total unsicher Phase. Und dann haben wir uns gefreut, dass uns jemand fragt. Und seitdem haben sie angefangen alle auch für Oma Krause ihre WLAN-Access Points zuzunageln. Jetzt ist überall Krypto an und jetzt kann man nicht mal mehr irgendwo auf der Parkbank seine Mail lesen.
Kann man das eigentlich wirklich nicht? Wie schwer ist das hackbar? Also ich habe immer das Gefühl, das kann eigentlich so gut. Gut, Krypto kann das eigentlich gar nicht sein.
Das Problem ist eigentlich, was da als Passwort grundsätzlich eingestellt ist. Aber ich glaube, da kann wirklich was zu erzählen.
Ach, da gibt es diverse Variationen. Also entweder der Name, also einfach ein Default-Passwort, was allen bekannt ist. Dann gibt es auch noch so Dinge wie, dass es dynamisch generiert wird, also boxspezifisch ist. Aber dann wird meistens so etwas wie die MAC-Adresse verwendet. Und die kriegt man halt auch raus, wenn man das WLAN sieht. Und daraus kann man sich dann das Passwort ableiten.
Eine MAC-Adresse ist der eindeutige Identifiziercode, den so eine Netzwerkkarte oder eine Funknetzwerkkarte immer so mitbringt. Die sollten eigentlich auch unique sein. Ich glaube, die sind auch bald alle, oder?
Ich dachte, die werden unique.
Die sind halbwegs unique. Also die werden für bestimmte Produkte recycelt, weil sie halt doch auch nicht endlos sind. Aber in der Regel sind sie halt weitersehend unique. Das Problem ist aber, dann holt man sich so einen Blog und das kostet Geld. Und sie sind halt auch knapp. Deswegen macht das meist der rote Hersteller und nicht der Hersteller des Chips für die Netzwahlkarte zum Beispiel. Und deswegen hat auch die Netzwahlkarte nicht eine komplett andere Markadresse wie das WLAN-Modul da drin. Sprich, lange Rede, gar keinen Sinn. Der Gedanke war, wir nehmen einfach die Markadresse vom Ethernet-Port. Den sieht der User ja zu Hause, das ist ja Kabelnetz. Und generieren daraus das Passwort für das WLAN. Was dann allerdings problematisch ist, wenn die Markadressen zwei sind, die aufeinander folgen sind.
Also man konnte dann einfach MAC-Adresse des WLANs plus eins oder minus eins probieren, was dann halt die MAC-Adresse des LANs war. Und daraus das Passwort generieren.
Mit anderen Worten, wir haben nichts gelernt. Es ist 2013 und wir haben nichts gelernt.
Auf der anderen Seite, da ist ja meistens nichts wertvolles. Ich meine, da ist wie zu Hause halt der Drucker, den irgendwie 10.000 Seiten Schwarzdruck...
Na ja, Störerhaftung, ne? Also das ist halt...
Oh, großes Thema.
Naja, aber das ist ja eigentlich das Problem. Das Problem ist ja nicht, dass jemand auf mein Netzwerk zugreift, da pfeife ich halt drauf. Das Problem ist, was der dann mit meinem Internetanschluss macht.
Na, noch, aber mit der ganzen Hausautomation. Stell dir vor, wie... naja gut, du wirst wahrscheinlich noch keinen Fahrstuhl haben in deinem Haus, aber... Ja, stell dir vor, dass dort irgendwas Kritisches mit geregelt wird, wo du nicht möchtest, dass da Leute direkt drauf können. Gut, das sollte man dann vielleicht noch mit irgendwas anderem als nur deinem WLAN schützen, aber... zumindest ist dann schon mal die erste Hürde genommen. Du guckst immer so zur Uhr rüber.
Ja, ich gucke immer zur Uhr rüber.
Langweilig war dich.
Nee, ich gucke immer zur Uhr rüber, weil es mein Beruf ist, auch immer zur Uhr rüber zu gucken.
Das macht die Folgen fein gemacht.
Das ist so, als wenn du auf dieser Seite dieses Tisches sitzt und hier auf die Knöpfe drückst und so, da achtest du immer ein bisschen auf die Uhrzeit. Da musst du jetzt leider durch... Ich kann das Einzige, was ich meinen kann, ist, ich kann diesen Monitor so weit hochfahren, dass du mich nicht mehr siehst. Aber ansonsten ja, ich gucke halt einfach immer zur Uhr.
Wobei ich sagen muss, dass diese neue Uhr echt nicht... Also das früher war schöner.
Weil das Hardware war, ne?
Ja, also so mit...
Na beschreib doch mal den Zuhörern.
Na ja, es ist so ein Gorgi-Timer, ne? Also Radio-Uhr.
Also früher hingen ja so eine LED-Uhr und außenrum so Plastoboxen oder mit Metallboxen, mit so einer Kunststoffplatte vorne drauf in bunten Farben. Dahinter eine Lampe. Hinter der Lautlampe war irgendwie ein Blitzlicht. Und wenn man dann irgendwie ganz laut ins Mikro gesprochen hat, hat das angefangen zu blitzen.
Achso, das kannst du immer noch damit und mach mal. Nee, geht nicht, da ist dann die Technik dahinter. Warte mal, ich versuch mal mit Musik, warte mal.
Das ist, glaub ich, einfach mal langsam.
Ist nicht mehr blau.
Jetzt läuft halt so ein, es fühlt sich an wie eine Flash-Applikation, die da läuft, die anscheinend auch ein bisschen Zeit braucht, bevor sie dann anfängt langsam oben dieses Pegel...
Auf einem riesigen Fernseher.
Nee, das war einfach nicht laut genug, ich hab die Musik nicht laut genug gekriegt.
Aber diese riesigen Fernseher erinnern mich so in die CeBIT, wo ich da mit so der TV-Bigan durch die Gegend gelaufen bin, um die dann einfach auszuschnüpfen und ich glaub...
Hast du dabei? Hast du mit?
Nee.
Ach Mist.
Nee, das mach ich immer nur, wenn Fußball-WM ist. Dann lohnt sich das ja auch so richtig.
Du bist das also. Wir wissen ja, wo du wohnst. Da schicke ich dann mal einen Fan-Beauftragten vorbei.
Ein Fan-Betreuer.
Hier, wollen wir von Nachrichten noch kurz einen Rant hören? Hörerschafts-Rant?
Wollen wir mal reinlassen?
Okay, wollen wir reinlassen. Guten Abend, Carsten.
Guten Abend.
Du wolltest einen Rant loslassen?
Ja, genau.
Bitte.
Also ich hab jetzt letztens auf diversen Word-Seiten gelesen, dass die Netzbetreiber, beziehungsweise die ISPs, die mir das Internet gefälligst zur Verfügung zu stellen haben, die dürfen jetzt sogar noch entscheiden, was ich für Plastorouter da hinstellen darf. Das heißt, ich darf überhaupt nicht mehr entscheiden, was für ein Endgerät ich am Schluss benutze. Kann das sein?
Na ja, das kann man grundsätzlich in irgendwie das Angebot mit inkludieren, was du da mit denen hast. Also dass du dir irgendwie im Rahmen das Vertrags, den du mit denen schließt. Das war halt bisher nicht usus, weil ein Inter-Provider, der liefert dir halt irgendwie Bits auf einem Draht. Und was du dann damit machst, war mittlerweile Wurst, nachdem das Ganze mit dem Postboden usw. endlich abgeschafft wurde. Aber das ist mittlerweile wieder wohl im Kommen, dass dann da einem Vorschriften gemacht werden.
Ich kann das mal überhaupt nicht verstehen. Wir telefonieren hier im Moment gerade über zwei Fritzboxen verteilt. An diesen Fritzboxen hängen noch diverse PCs und NAS- und FDPs da, was weiß ich. Und hinterher stellen die mir da irgendeinen Popel-Ding hin, von dem ich noch nicht mal Filmbeupdates machen darf.
Was ich gar nicht verstehe, ist das eine Prozent.
Die wollen dir ja auch noch Zusatzdienstleistung verkaufen.
Aber wie wollen die denn überhaupt merken, die was ich da für ein Gerät dran habe? Ist jetzt wieder die Frage wie eben beim Modem. Tatsächlich, das schickt eine Kennung.
Die handeln dann so Dinge aus und das ist ein Geheimnis.
Das können wir später noch vertiefen, wenn wir ein bisschen mehr Zeit haben. Das gibt da TR69, was ein Provisionierungsprotokoll ist, um so gut da zu konfigurieren von Providerseite und so weiter. Und die bieten einem jetzt ja nicht nur Internet an, sondern viele, viele andere Dienste. Und das funktioniert nur mit deren Equipment. Und damit du diese Dienste nutzen kannst, wollen sie natürlich, dass du da Equipment hast, was genau das tut. Und da jetzt zu sagen, nee nutze ich nicht, geht nach Hause, ich will hier nur Internet, wird halt zunehmend schwierig. Zunehmend schwieriger.
Ja, weil, wie gesagt, ich sehe mich ja eher so als, naja, Power User ist so ein übertriebenes Wort, aber ich verstehe einigermaßen, was auf diesem Plastikding, was ja inzwischen alles kann, was da so abläuft.
Ich finde das jetzt nichts Besonderes. Du willst dich einfach nur nicht bevormunden lassen. Da soll bei dir zu Hause gefälligst Internet aus der Wand kommen. Und damit willst du machen, was du willst. Und da soll dir nicht irgendjemand vorschreiben, dass du jetzt irgendwie nur, keine Ahnung, ob du noch das AOL-Portal klicken kannst oder CompuServe oder wie sie alle damals hießen.
Habt ihr manchmal eigentlich das Gefühl, dass dieser Kampf verloren ist?
Wenn sich immer Mittel und Wege finden, und am Ende sind die Leute auch zu träge, um sich da den ganzen neuen Scheiß zu kaufen.
Das hat schon irgendwie Beschwerden auch vor im Niveau, aber man muss es schon tun, weil Freiheit und Reue verteidigt werden.
Die Sache ist ja, ich als ganz normaler Nutzer in Anführungszeiten, die auch irgendwo die Wahl haben.
Du bist kein ganz normaler Nutzer. Der ganz normale Nutzer will eben nicht die Wahl haben. So ein ganz normaler Nutzer ist der Typ, der packt das Ding aus, klemmt das an, und dann muss das spielen. Also eher so pfeifen wie ich.
Solange das tut, dann interessiert es den Kunden ja nicht. Deswegen gibt es auch keinen Druck auf die Hersteller, irgendwie mal Firmware-Updates bereitzustellen, Sicherheitsupdates, weil es funktioniert ja. Der Kunde hat Internet, die Bandbreiten sind groß genug, dass wenn da irgendwelche Daten noch übergehen, von Botnetzen und so weiter, dass es der Endkunde einfach nicht mehr bemerkt.
Oder vielleicht ist es einfach nur Ass-Covering, dass sie nicht wollen, dass dort ihre Support-Hotlines mit Leutenfolge gequatscht werden, die die komischsten Geräte daran haben und dann halt nicht das Protokoll befolgen können, so jetzt klickt mal da ein, klickt mal da ein, jetzt ist wieder heile. Sondern wenn du eine Fritzbox dran hast, dann, ja keine Ahnung, noch nie gehört, schönen Tag.
Du willst es halt standardisieren im Zweifelsfall, weil du so viele Kunden hast, dass du nicht alle Fälle abdecken kannst.
Dann ist dann wahrscheinlich da auch eher so, ruf uns nicht an, weil du hast die falsche HW am Start.
Welchen Provider bist du, Karsten?
Ich bin bei 1&1, bzw. da ich nicht selber die Rechnungen bezahle, ist das sozusagen die Familie, die das im Moment für mich bezahlt, solange ich noch daheim wohne. Und bei denen geht das ja, Gott sei Dank. Aber wenn ich da nur an die Telekom denke, die einen sogar, wenn man aus Versehen sie vertippt, bei der URL, beim Browser und dann tippt man, was weiß ich, keine Ahnung.
Die Navigationshilfe.
Ja, die Navigationshilfe.
Ich hab die, ich schalt die täglich aus, täglich. Das ist so unglaublich.
Da verdient die Telekom sogar noch da dran, wenn man sich vertippt, weil sie da Werbung draufschalten.
Das ist sehr, sehr lustig. Und dann steht unten immer, möchten Sie die Navigationshilfe ausschalten? Dann klicken Sie mal hier, dann kommst du ins Kundencenter, schalt die Navigationshilfe aus und sagen, jetzt müssen Sie noch mal Ihren Router neu starten, das machst du und dann ist hinterher die Navigationshilfe wieder da. Das ist richtig übel. Und wenn du nicht weißt, was du dann machen sollst... Also für mich hörte es nicht, dass ich gesagt hab, kommst du ins Kundencenter und ich hoffe, du läufst mit dem Baseball-Schieber an dieses Kundencenter. Nee, nee, du kommst dann ins Kundencenter, das in 80% der Fälle nicht funktioniert, weil gerade Wartungsarbeiten sind.
Und dann auch nur mit Interdexplorer Version 6 oder so?
Nee, da sind sie aber schon recht weit vorne.
Ich nehme Ihren Anruf sehr ernst.
Dann schaltest du die Navigationshilfe aus, vertippst dich wieder, dann kommt die Navigationshilfe wieder. Und irgendwann sagst du, okay, 8888. Dann zieht die Schnauze voll.
Das Kundencenter ist eben das, was nicht mehr auf dem Router liegt. Das heißt, man hat keinen Zugriff mehr auf seinen Router, sondern man geht in die Cloud auf irgendeine Webseite, stellt da seine Daten ein, wie wir zum Beispiel irgendwie die Navigationshilfe ausschalten.
Was macht das, setzt das ein Cookie auf den Router?
Nee, dann soll das über TR-69 oder sonstige Provisionierungsprotokolle dem Router sagen, dass es die Navigationshilfe ausschalten soll. Oder, ja, es wird auf Provider-Seite gemacht, aber dieses TR-069 funktioniert eh nicht so wirklich. Das ist eine 190 Seiten Spezifikation zur Provisionierung, die so schwammig geschrieben ist, dass es niemand richtig implementiert bekommt und alle sind incompatibel zueinander.
Und was Provisionierung ist, das erfahrt ihr nach den Nachrichten. Carsten, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Wir müssen Nachrichten machen.
Bitte und tschüss.
Chaosradio 188 ist hier und gleich geht's weiter.
Im September gibt's wieder das schönste Open-Air-Festival for all friends of German Lyrics. Und zwar gleich zwei Tage lang. Freitag, 6. September mit Philip Poisel. Und einen Tag später mit Bosse. Mit Mega-Mega, Exclusive und Sportfreunde Stiller. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle. Karten gibt's überall wo's Karten gibt. Im Kombiticket für beide Tage. Oder einzeln für Freitag oder Samstag. Die neuen Deutschpoeten 2013.
Mit Philipp Berger.
In Italien ist die Bildung einer neuen Regierung gescheitert. Die Sondierungsgespräche des Linkspolitikers Pierluigi Bersani mit den anderen Parteien waren nicht erfolgreich. Das hat Bersani am Abend Italiens Staatspräsident Napolitano mitgeteilt. Die Regierungsbildung ist schwierig, weil aus der Wahl Ende Februar drei nahezu gleich starke Lager hervorgegangen waren, ohne dass es einen eindeutigen Sieger gab. Journalisten, die für den Münchner NSU-Prozess zugelassen sind, dürfen ihren Platz jetzt doch mit anderen Reportern tauschen. Das hat das Oberlandesgericht München entschieden. Bei der Vergabe der 50 festen Plätze waren Journalisten von türkischen Medien leer ausgegangen, obwohl die meisten Opfer der Neonazi-Mordserie einen türkischen Migrationshintergrund hatten. Dies hatte im In- und Ausland scharfen Protest ausgelöst. Grundsätzlich, so das Münchner Gericht, bleibe es jedoch bei der Akkreditierungsliste. Sie werde nicht erweitert. Auf mehreren Autobahnen in Brandenburg standen die Fahrer am Abend zum Teil stundenlangen Staus. Nach einem Lkw-Unfall musste der südliche Berliner Ring die A10 in Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz gesperrt werden. Es bildeten sich bis zu 20 km lange Rückstaus auf der A2 ab Brandenburg und auf der A9 ab Netzen. Auf der A24 gab es in Richtung Norden nach einer Karambulage ab Sukho eine Vollsperrung. Mehr zur aktuellen Situation hört ihr gleich im Fritz Verkehrsservice. In der zweiten Fußballbundesliga hat Energie Cottbus zu Hause gegen den VFR Alen gespielt. Die Partie endete unentschieden 1 zu 1. Und wir schließen mit einer erfreulichen Meldung. Brandenburgs Sportvereine haben so viele Mitglieder wie nie zuvor. Zum ersten Mal in seiner Geschichte zählt der Landessportbund mehr als 320.000 Mitglieder. Das sind über 4.000 mehr als im vergangenen Jahr. Und das, obwohl die Bevölkerung älter und weniger wird. Damit gehören fast 13% aller Brandenburger einem Sportverein an.
Wetter.
Die aktuellen Temperaturen betragen im Moment zwischen minus 2 und ein Grad plus in Berlin und Brandenburg. Und stehen vermutlich weiße Ostern, bevor immer wieder Schnee kann heute Nacht fallen, vor allem im südlichen Brandenburg, aber auch tagsüber im gesamten Sendegebiet. Die Temperaturen sollen erst ab Ostermontag ein wenig nach oben gehen. Autobahn 2, Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Es gibt immer noch Stau zwischen Wollin und Dreieck Werder. A10, südlicher Berliner Ring, Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Hier gibt es Stau zwischen Dreieck Werder und Dreieck Potsdam. Da geht der Stau also einfach weiter. A12, Berlin Richtung Frankfurt, zwischen Biegener Hellen und Frankfurt West. Lkw-Stau in Richtung Polen. Die Gegenrichtung A12, Frankfurt Richtung Berlin. Bitte Vorsicht an der Ausfahrt Fürstenwalde West. Steht ein kaputtes Auto auf der Verzögerungsspur. A20, Kreuz Uckermark, Richtung Rostock. Zwischen Kreuz Uckermark und Prenzlau Süd steht ein kaputtes Fahrzeug auf der Fahrbahn. In Berlin ist die B96 im Tunnel Tiergarten im Moment nicht durchgängig befahrbar. Der Tunnel ist zwischen Reichpeach Ufer bis Heidestraße gesperrt. Und bei der S-Bahn Linie 1 fahren seit 22 Uhr bis Sonntag Betriebsschluss. Keine Züge zwischen Wannsee und Sundgauer Straße. Es werden Busse eingesetzt. Gute Fahrt.
Danke Philipp, neun Minuten nach Elbels.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Chaosradio 188 ist hier und heute geht's um Ruta. Also diese Kästen, wo das Internet drin ist, das wir alle zu Hause haben. Mit dabei sind der Erdgeist, der Mirk und der Nibbler.
Guten Abend.
Wo waren wir denn eigentlich stehen? Ah genau, ich wollte fragen, was ist denn bitte, ich kann meine eigene Schrift nicht mehr lesen. Provisionierung. Was ist denn bitte Provisionierung?
Das kommt bestimmt von Profi, oder?
Stimmt, so wie profilaktisch.
Na, irgendwoher muss ja deine Plaste Box wissen, wer du bist und wie viel von diesem Internet du gekauft hast.
Deine Zugangsdaten und was verdienst du noch so hast, wie mobile Internet-Telefonie.
Genau, Telefonnummern, Zugangsdaten und all der Kram. Und den möchte der Kunde jedenfalls nicht manuell eintragen. Und deswegen kann der Internet Service Provider diese Daten für dich auf deinen Router eintragen, aus der Cloud, über spezielle Provisionierungsprotokolle, wie zum Beispiel TR-069.
Das war das mit dieser 200-seitigen Spezifikation?
War das nicht nur die Übersicht oder ist das die komplette Speck?
Ich glaube, das war nur ein Teil. Es gibt auch noch TR-064 und diverse andere.
TR ist Telecom Telephony Recommendation. Das heißt, das ist ein Standard, den sich Telcos zusammen ausgedacht haben und als Empfehlung herausgeben für Hersteller und dergleichen. Ich glaube, da sind auch Hersteller mit beteiligt gewesen von so Geräten. Aber es ist halt so ein Industriekonsortium, das versucht sich auf einen Standard zu einigen. Und das geht dann meist damit aus, dass so ein Standard dann zwar da ist, auch ganz viel Text hat, aber nicht so eindeutig, dass da irgendwie...
Das Ganze ist vor allem XML über HTTP. Also sehr schmal und zuverlässig und einfach zu passen.
Das ist so ein Programmiererwitz. Das heißt, wenn deine Applikation noch nicht kompliziert genug ist und noch nicht genug potenzielle Fehlerquellen aufweist, dann machst du am Ende noch irgendwie XML-RPC und dann machst du das noch über HTTP, unter bestem Video, über so einen Windows-Web-Server, so ein IIS und dann hast du irgendwie genug Komplexität, dass du irgendwie für den Rest deines Lebens ausgesorgt hast.
Mit Support-Verträgen.
Dann gibt es natürlich noch undokumentierte Stapel an Notizzetteln bei irgendwelchen Developern neben dem Bildschirm oder so, wie denn genau dieses XML nicht zu pasen und zu pasen ist, weil wenn man bestimmte Sachen ineinander schachtet, dann unvorhergesehene Dinge, wovon man selber weiß, die man aber dann nicht dekumentiert hat, weil es funktioniert ja mit dem Setup so, wie man es da hat. Man sollte nur da und da und da nichts ändern, weil sonst der Paser auf den Nase fliegt oder so.
Gerade bei den XML-Bibliotheken, die benutzt werden, gab es haufenweise Schwachstellen, Sicherheitslücken etc. Und da die Router auch nie geupdatet werden, aber von außen wundervoll erreichbar sind, kann man diese Lücken auch wunderbar ausnutzen.
Ich überlege gerade, ob mein Router jemals gesagt hat, er möchte jetzt ein Firmware-Update haben. Ich glaube, das hat er es noch nie gesagt.
Da musst du dich da auf dieser Seite einloggen. Dann kannst du wahrscheinlich irgendwo aus dem Internet, während du noch Internet hast am besten, dieses neue Firmware-Image runterladen. Dann kannst du das da wieder per Browser hochladen.
Aber das ist ja auch falsch.
Und wenn irgendwas schief geht, dann hast du kein Internet mehr, um nachzugucken, warum du denn jetzt plötzlich kein Internet mehr hast.
Da, der doch im Handy. Notfall. 0331 70 97 1, dann soll es unsere Nummer. Ihr seid herzlich eingeladen, euch zu beteiligen an dieser Sendung. Zum Beispiel so wie der Matthias. Der wollte auch noch mal von früher erzählen, Erdgeist.
Genau.
Na ja, früher haben wir bald, hoffe ich doch. Nachdem dann der Winter weg ist.
Ah, Wortspiel.
Ich hab grad gehört, weiße Ostern.
Ja, genau das. Weil ihr von lustigen kleinen Plastikschachteln euch unterhaltet.
Oh, mach mal dein Radio aus.
Wollte ich mal erzählen, weil du in kleiner Zeit war, als es noch keine kleinen Plastikschachteln gab, sondern wo man mit viel Mühe sich sein erstes ADSL-Modem bei der Telekom geleistet hat und an Ermangelung oder Ausermangelung dann einen alten Rechner hernehmen musste, der dann Router gespielt hat.
Entschuldige kurz, in Ermangelung müsste es heißen.
Was hast du draufgefahren? Man Drake Linux, soweit ich weiß.
Doch noch ganz früher.
Und dann mit den Skripten und Fetter hat man sich dann quasi seinen Router selber gebastelt.
Das war genau zu den Zeiten, wo man mit Internet zu versorgen. Ja, es ist noch so keine kleinen, billigen Cluster-Router oder fertige Boards, wo man so Linux drauffahren konnte, wie heute der Raspberry Psi. Musste man damals so richtig Hardware nehmen, wo noch ein großer Lüfter drin war und Netzteile und alles mögliche. Dann stand der da irgendwie im Flur oder in der Küche, wo man den hingestellt hat und machte einfach Lärm und Dreck und einfach nur dafür, dass Internet ist.
Kennt ihr noch FLIR? Das war so eine Linux-Distribution auf Diskette. Die konnte man dann in normale Rechner reinstecken und hatte dann FLIR. Das war LFLI4L. Das war so eine Diskettendistribution extra für Router. Jetzt hab ich auch Router gesagt.
Er hat Router gesagt. Toll, da hast du was angerichtet.
Ja, echt. Die Kunst oder der Sport war ja dabei, möglichst in den Rechner zu nehmen, der natürlich von der Hardware-Anforderung nicht so doll sein wusste. Ich erinnere mich, ich glaube, das war 2000 rum. Da war das wie ein alter 386. Da lieferten so eine Disketten...
Das frisst doch Strom.
Und den hat man aber lufterlos gemacht. Den hat man runtergestrippt ohne Ende. Möglichst Sparflamme.
Ich war meist schon zufrieden, wenn erst mal überhaupt Internet war. Und danach machst du bloß wieder Dinge kaputt.
Das ist wohl richtig. Aber das hat funktioniert ziemlich lange sogar ziemlich gut. Tschüss. Hamba.
Da entwickelte sich ja dieses Hackerbild davon, was so ein Router eigentlich sein sollte. Ein Stück eigener Hardware oder zumindest Hardware, die du unter deiner Kontrolle hast. Und darauf dann... Er steht halt zu Hause in deinem Netz. Und du möchtest nicht, dass irgendjemand anders, der da in einem Rechenzentrum sitzt, vielleicht ein gelangweiter Mitarbeiter in seiner Nachtschicht, der da mal guckt, was klicken die dann so und dort mal anfängt, noch Software zu deployen.
Guck mal, immer wenn er U-Porn guckt, ist er mit dem Firefox unterwegs, weil man im Privatmodus schalten kann. Geschenke kaufen, genau. Wir hatten ja eben diesen Routerzwang, da gibt es jetzt den Dirk, der möchte da für Aufklärung sagen. Hallo, der Dirk. Ja, hallo.
Ja, wie ihr sagt, ich arbeite bei so einem Anbieter in der Hotline.
Ne, musst du nicht sagen.
Holgi ist eben mein Anbieter. Ja, und zwar, es ist einfach so, also jeder Kunde kriegt bei uns ja so einen Router erst mal zu dem Anschluss. Inzwischen auch nur noch WLAN-Router. Früher haben sie mal Modem gekriegt oder eben Router ohne WLAN oder nur Einzelplatznutzung und so. Und dann kriegen sie inzwischen halbwie vernünftige Räder. Das Standard Ding halt, vier Anschlüsse hinten und WLAN. Und die Kunden sagen dann, ja, ich will aber meinen eigenen benutzen. So und ich sag da dem Kunden immer, solange ihr Anschluss funktioniert, können sie benutzen, was sie wollen. Mach mal ihnen überhaupt keine Vorschriften. Aber wenn der Kunde dann Störungen hat und Support will, dann soll er halt wenigstens für diesen Zeitraum, wenn der Anschluss mal nicht funktioniert, wenigstens den Router anschließen, den er von seinem Anbieter gekriegt hat.
Also Dinge aus dem Keller holen.
Genau so ungefähr. Weil die Sache ist einfach mal, wenn du Support leisten willst, dann musst du ja auch irgendwo wissen, was hängt da hinten dran, wie verhält sich das Gerät. Dann fragst du denen die Lampen an, blinkt denn die DSL-Lampe und bei einer Fritzbox blinkt eben nicht die DSL-Lampe. Da blinkt dann eben die Power-Lampe und alles Mögliche. Und wenn der Kunde dann selber damit nicht klarkommt, wie er sagt, er kann anschließen, was er will, es sei denn, er hat eine Störung und will Support, dann soll er auch das anschließen, was er von seinem Anbieter gekriegt hat. Die Ausnahme ist, das habt ihr auch schon angesprochen, Thema Professionierung und so, diese ganzen Next-Generation-Network-Anschlüsse, also Voice-OVIP-Anschlüsse, da kannst du halt meistens nur den Router benutzen, den du von deinem Anbieter gekriegt hast. Weil dort die Protokolle drin sind, die Zugangsdaten.
Das Problem ist ja auch dem Kunden einfach nicht zu muten, zu können mehr als einen Benutzernamen und Kennwort. Und das ist ja schon oft schwierig einzutragen. So, und trägst du nochmal die Telefonnummer für deinen SIP-Anschluss ein, dann konfigurierst du nochmal das richtige PV-ID und das richtige WLAN für dein Entertainment-Fernsehpaket. Und dann hast du noch dit und dit und den PV6-Präfix für Telefonie und deinen Kühlschrank kriegst du ein anderes. Also, der Anzahl der Arameter ist einfach viel zu viel.
Zumal dort automatisch bei manchen Iretten auch regelmäßig neue Firmware aufgespielt wird. Und spätestens dann, wenn er dann kein Iret von dem Anbieter dran hat, kommt es dann halt zu einem Konflikt, wo dann die Vermittlungsschwelle sagt, was ist denn jetzt los? Das Iret kenne ich nicht, der reagiert nicht, das blockiert und so weiter.
Dann schalte ich mich lieber mal aus. Dann sagt die Vermittlungsschwelle, ich schalte mich jetzt lieber mal aus.
Sicher ist sicher.
Genau.
Und dann gibt es einen Anruf und in zwei mein Anschluss schickt nicht.
Das Problem ist hauptsächlich, dass wenn ein Kunde jetzt ein ähnliches Gerät anschließt und dann die Provider Firmware gepusht bekommt über THR 69 mit einem Update, hier holt er mal neue Firmware und sich dann diese neue Firmware holt, die aber nicht zu dem Board, was in dieser Box verbaut ist, passt, weil das eine andere Charge ist, wird das halt schwierig. Aber man muss damit rechnen, dass irgendwie ein Teil der Boxen, die man so als Netzbetreiber hat, man ja nicht nur irgendwie 20 Kunden, sondern man hat da irgendwie hunderttausende von Boxen draußen und da ist einfach eine bestimmte Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es ein kleiner einstelliger Prozentsatz, wenn man eins bei vielleicht drei Prozent, die einfach nach so einem Firmware Update auch nicht wiederkommen. Also wo halt irgendwas daneben geht und man dann mit dem Kunden ja dem neue Box rausschicken darf. Da steht auch Firmware Updates regelmäßigen im Weg. Also da sind wir echt in einer Steinzeit.
Also man will es halt auch alles automatisieren. Dazu hilft es halt, wenn dort einheitliche Räte beim Kunden stehen. Und Automatisierung heißt einfach, es wird auch immer preiswerter für den Anbieter. Und ich sag mal letztlich, das bedingt ja auch der Kunde. Der ist ja auch immer billiger. Und das ist so was, was mich am meisten immer ärgert bei unseren Kunden. Die wollen immer einen vollen Support und einen besten Service. Aber für am besten umsonst ist es noch zu teuer.
Den Service will ich ja gar nicht, ich will ja einfach nur schnelles Internet. Und vor allem nicht runtergedrosseltes Internet hab irgendwann. Was wir jetzt dann wieder nächst einführen. Das wird dann wahrscheinlich in den Callcentern auch nochmal ganz lustig werden.
Meinst du, die führen das ein? Bringen die das wirklich?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, das ist jetzt ein Testballon, der da...
Mal gucken, ja klar. Mal gucken, wie die Netzgemeinde das diskutiert.
Wie interessiert ihr noch, weil der Dirk arbeitet in so einem Callcenter? Kannst du erzählen, was der schlimmste Kunde gewesen ist, mit dem du da jemals telefonieren musstest?
Boah, der schlimmste Kunde, weiss ich nicht, irgendwie... Richtig schlimme Kunden hat man eigentlich so, weiss ich nicht, alle paar Tage oder so irgendwie, wo man dann auch anschließend... Also ich bin da manchmal auch so, dass ich das dann nach dem Gespräch nicht verjette, sondern wirklich erst mal rausgehen muss, Pausen machen muss und mal wieder runterkommen muss.
Was machen die? Also sind die so insgesamt einfach anstrengend, weil sie doof sind? Oder schnauzen die dich die ganze Zeit an, so dass du irgendwann durch bist?
Oder beides? Also dumme Leute nerven einen einfach total. Wenn Leute einfach von nichtsen planen, wenn du damit den Router einrichten willst und dann sagst du, klicken sie jetzt dort und dann kommt die Frage links oder rechts klicken? Ja, linke Maustaste. Einmal oder zweimal? Einmal klicken. Okay, dann beim nächsten Mal Kontextmüh. Klicken sie da mit der rechten Maustaste.
Fragt man sich auch mal, haben sie keine Enkel, die ihnen das mal eben schnell hier...
Ja, nee, das ist irgendwie die Leute. Ich bin auch der Meinung, viele Leute sollten irgendwie erst mal einen Grundlagenkurs bei der Volkshochschule machen, wie bediene ich einen Computer oder so.
Ja, es gab früher, ich weiß noch gar nicht, der Internetführerschein von Web.de. Das war total super, das habe ich meinem Vater übergeholfen. Das gab es damals auf CD-ROM.
Ach echt, gab es sowas?
Den Web.de-Internetführerschein. Das war total cool, das habe ich meinem Vater in die Hand gekriegt, er hat gesagt, schieb das in deinen Computer. Und er hat das kapiert. Ich habe es dann, das ist über 10 Jahre her. Keine Ahnung, ob es das noch gibt. Aber es wäre super, wenn man sowas mal entwickeln würde. Also irgendwie einfach ein Computerführerschein für...
Dirk, wie ist denn prozentual die Verteilung an Power-Usern oder an Leuten, die glauben, sie hätten Ahnung, haben sie aber nicht oder an kompletten Anfängern?
Nicht eingeschlossen, ich glaube ja auch immer, dass ich Ahnung habe.
Nee, ich meinte jetzt eher an Anrufern bei der Hotline.
Ein Kollege fragt mich gerade, ob ich das im Radio bin.
Nee, bist du nicht. Das ist nicht der Dirk. Das sind nicht die Druiden, die ihr sucht.
Wurde dir jetzt gerade das Maulkorb vom Kollegen übergeholfen?
Nee, es ist privat, ist ein Kollege der Fernseher, okay.
Muss der jetzt sagen.
Gibt es eigentlich irgendwie so den geheimen Trick, dieses Protokoll, das ihr da abarbeiten müsst, zu umgehen? Weil das ist so mein Problem, wenn ich dann mal die Hotline anrufe und sage so, pass mal auf, das und das geht nicht, das und das sollte so und so. Schibolett.
Genau, ja genau.
Sitzt bei Ihnen irgendwo jemand, der einen Pinguin auf dem Schreibtisch hat. Nein, gibt es irgendeine Möglichkeit, das zu umgehen? Oder seid ihr bei Strafe verpflichtet, dieses Protokoll einzuhalten? Also wenn ich dich anrufe, dann fragst du ja immer dieselben Sachen.
Ja.
Blinkt das, leuchtet das, stecken sie es mal an, stecken sie es mal ab. Und meistens, also bevor ich eine Hotline anrufe, habe ich schon alles gemacht, was ich mir nur vorstellen kann, was ich irgendwie machen kann. Inklusive irgendwo in Foren rumgeguckt, was das Problem sein könnte und sowas. Und wenn ich dann anrufe und sage, pass auf mal auf, ich habe das alles schon ausprobiert, können wir direkt auf Stufe 2 gehen? Dann funktioniert das immer nicht. Was muss ich tun?
Ja, also ich sage mal, daran hat der Action dort in der Hotline selber nicht unbedingt ein Interesse, das zu gehen, es sei denn, es wird für ihn ein schnelles Gespräch. Aber die Sache ist einfach, jeder Kunde sagt, ich habe schon alles probiert. Haben Sie denn die Originalverkabelung hergestellt? Ja klar, sicher, also habe ich schon immer.
Ich habe nichts geändert.
Wie viele Meter sind es denn von der Telefondose bis zum Splitter?
Zwölf.
Ja, ja, das ist das Originalkabel. Na wie weit ist denn das? So ein Meter? Na ja, so sechs, sieben Meter. Dann stellen Sie mal unsere Originalverkabelung her, so wie das vorgesehen ist. Und dann guckst du fünf Minuten später auf die Leitung drauf und dann ist er auf immer von zwei MBit auf 16 MBit hoch. Aber der Kunde hat alles richtig gemacht und das ging ja schon immer so.
Und ich hab nix geändert.
Nee, ich hab nix geändert. Und seit ich Windows 8 gehabt hab, geht das nicht mehr. Das muss an Ihnen liegen. Das sind so die Standardantworten. Da fängst du irgendwann an zu verzweifeln. Und was Holger sagt mit der Strafe. Also du hast einen Ablaufplan, du hast dort entsprechende Programme, die dich dann fragen. A, B fragen, eventuell noch C und dann klicken. Und ja, hat er schon gemacht und so weiter. Und der Strafe kann man so eigentlich nicht sagen. Du hast natürlich ein Interesse daran, das so auch abzuarbeiten. Einfach mal, du willst dir auch jeden Kunden letztlich den gleichen Service-Level liefern. Und wenn du jetzt, also so eine Beispiele, zum Beispiel Kunde benutzt Linux. Ich hab zu Hause auch nur Linux auf meinem Rechner. Wir supporten halt Windows, die gängigen Systeme und Mac OS. Und wenn jetzt ein Kunde mit Linux kommt, kannst du dem, wenn du es weißt, sicher helfen. Das heißt dann aber auch, ruft er irgendwann wieder an. Der Kollege hat dann keine Ahnung, oder hält sie an seine Anweisung. Dann heißt es natürlich, ja, aber der Kollege beim letzten Mal hat mir doch auch mit Linux geholfen. Wieso können Sie denn das jetzt? Geben Sie den mir doch mal. Ja, der ist gerade im Urlaub. Ja, das ist mir doch jetzt eh an.
Wobei ich das Problem hatte, ich hab mal Third-Level-Support für einen ISP gemacht.
Was ist Third-Level-Support?
Na du hast verschiedene Level. Machst du irgendwie Frontline? Ja, das sind die Leute, die du anrufst, wenn du irgendwie die 0800er Nummer deines Telefonanbieters mit irgendwie Millionen Kunden anrufst, da kriegst du halt irgendwie einen von ex-100 Corsinter-Mitarbeitern, der mit dir wirklich grundlegenden Dingen durchgeht und das kann dann raufeskaliert werden. Also je nachdem, wie spezifisch dein Problem ist, dann entsprechend zu Leuten, die ein bisschen mehr Planen haben und wenn es wirklich ein harter Fall ist, dann kriegt das auch mal irgendwann Techniker auf dem Tisch, bei denen auch daran interessiert sind.
Das heißt, du bist derjenige, zu dem ich komme, wenn ich Schibulett sage?
Weiß ich nicht. Also in dem Fall war es halt, dass wir ein paar Probleme hatten und wir uns Chaos rausgenommen haben, die auf eine bestimmte Problematik gepasst haben, weil wir einfach gucken wollten, wie sieht unser Problem aus, wie ist die Anotamin des Problems, wie lösen wir das? Und da brauchst du einfach Kunden, mit denen du dann genau dieses spezifische Problem analysierst. Und da hatten wir einen, der mir reingereicht wurde, mit, ja, das ist ein User, der hat so ein NETBSD am Laufen. Weiß jetzt auch nicht, das muss wohl irgendwie so was wie links. Gib mir den mal, gib mir den mal. Und mit dem konnte man dann tatsächlich, ich wollte dir sagen, kannst du mir mal hier TCPdump, mal einen PCAP zuschicken, guck ich mal rein. Und hatten wir auch innerhalb von weniger als zwei Tagen das Problem abschließend gelöst gehabt. Also gibt's schon Kunden, über die man als ISP sehr froh ist, weil sie auf der anderen Seite dann schon einem Input liefern können, der einem weiterbringt.
Dirk, danke für deinen Anruf. Jetzt haben wir immerhin gelernt, wie wir mit den Leuten an der Hotline sprechen müssen, wie wir maximal auf den Keks gehen können.
Das reicht ja erstmal höflich, ne?
Ach höflich.
Du bist immer so komisch irgendwie.
Höflich richtig. Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Mittlerweile ist es immer noch eine. Hier ist Chaosradio 188 mit dem Erdgeist Möko, Nibbler und Holgi. Und wenn wir damit durch sind, f'en wir uns nach.
Ich bin Robin, ich hab das eigentlich gesagt, aber ist ja egal.
Hallo Robin, ist Windows.
Ich wollte eigentlich mit euch mal kurz über das Thema sprechen, auch zum Thema fangesteuerte Router, also sprich fangesteuert durch den Internet Service Provider. Und ihr habt ja vorhin schon ein bisschen geredet, dass wir über Sicherheitslücken in Routern sowohl durch WLAN als auch über das Internet. Und mir ist da eigentlich so ein bisschen auch der Gedanke gekommen, ich hab da auch schon ein bisschen was drüber gelesen, wenn jetzt sozusagen ein Provider wie jetzt nach der Telekom mit diesem Deepboard Router zum Beispiel ein anderer Provider die Möglichkeit hat, den Router sozusagen über die eigene Server zu provisionieren und zu steuern, gäbe es ja eigentlich theoretisch auch die Möglichkeit, das wurde vorhin schon irgendwie hier gesagt, so ein Router könnte ja auch Bitcoins berechnen, so ein Botnetz irgendwie mit betreiben, gäbe ja eigentlich dann auch für die Möglichkeit vom Provider theoretisch irgendwas einzusteuern in der Router oder mich auch irgendwie vielleicht auszuspionieren, was ich so in meinem Netzwerk zum Beispiel noch habe.
Der Provider hat jederzeit die Möglichkeit, dir auch deinem Router, wenn es einer von denen ist, eine neue Firmware überzuhelfen und rein technisch gesehen hat der Provider jederzeit die Möglichkeit, dir da ein verbundesverstaatstreuernerten Router hinzustellen, also irgendeine Firmware, die schon auf dem Router in deinem Netzwerk zu Hause rumschnüffelt. Das können die rein technisch gesehen jederzeit sofort machen und auch ohne, dass du irgendwie da großen Überblick drüber hast.
Dafür brauchen die nicht mal Provisionierung.
Ohne, dass er einen großen Überblick hat oder ohne, dass überhaupt jemand einen großen Überblick darüber hat. Also würde man das überhaupt merken?
Na ja, da sind halt schon physikalisch die Bits im Flash deines Routers andere als vorher waren. Okay, aber wer guckt sich das an?
Na ich jeden Morgen.
Genau, morgens erst mal Bits zählen.
Aber dein Provider hat eh eine Übersicht über deinen kompletten Traffic, den kriegt er eh und den leitet er auch auf Anfrage zu Strafverfolgungsbehörden usw. Aber bei sowas wie Kabelnetzen ist eh hinter dem Modem, vor dem Modem, also was man also an Broadcast Traffic in so einem Doxys-Segment an einem Kabelnetz hinter seinem Modem wieder sieht von anderen Leuten ist spannend.
Weil jetzt zum Beispiel wenn es der Provider Zugriff hat, ich meine klar, dass der Provider natürlich meinen Traffic, den ich über das Internet rausjage und den ich irgendwie dazugespielt bekomme, über das Netz das sehen kann. Das ist mir klar, weil zum Beispiel eben über so einen freigesteuerten Looter, das macht ja einem auch zum Beispiel die Fehlkommensmachkraft, dass man zum Beispiel auch über das Kundencenter dann den Looter direkt steuern kann, quasi auch gar nicht mehr über die IP-Adresse da einloggen muss. Dann könnte ja theoretisch auf der Provider zum Beispiel vielleicht mal schauen, was mache ich in meinem Netzwerk oder auch wenn ich zum Beispiel irgendwie eine ungefützte Freigabe habe, weil ich mir denke, okay, mein Netzwerk ist geschützt, zum Beispiel aus WLAN. Könnte ja theoretisch über den Looter auch zum Beispiel auch auf eine Netzwerksfreigabe zugreifen und sowas.
In dem Moment, wo dein Provider sowas machen kann, gehört dir der Looter halt nicht. Also das sehe ich genauso wie mit Telefonen und allen anderen Hardware, auf denen ich nicht der einzige Herr im Hause bin und auf das Gerät quasi exklusiv Zugriff habe. So das ist dann halt eine Box, die dir nicht gehört, sondern deinem Anbieter. Und deswegen ist sowas halt schon sehr fragwürdig, ob die Vorteile, die man daraus gewinnt, dass irgendwie was flüssiger funktioniert und man jetzt eine Voice-over-IP-Telefone nicht konfigurieren muss, sondern das der Anbieter tut. Also ich weiß nicht den Vorteil von so einem Kundenportal im Internet gegenüber. Ich muss mich lokal auf eine Adresse einloggen. Sehe ich nicht, wenn ich dafür das Hausrecht auf meinem Plastorouter zu Hause verliere. Wobei eh die Frage ist, ob man der einzige Herr auf dem Gerät ist, weil die Software auf diesen Boxen ist jetzt nicht unbedingt von...
Ich würde da jetzt an der Stelle noch nicht so viel den Fokus auf die Plastorouter legen, weil was du dir allein mit deinem Mobiltelefon, wo ja irgendwie so ein verbogenes Betriebssystem drauf ist, dort in dein Heimnetzwerk reinschleppst, wo die Nachbarn drauf Zugriff haben, wie die dir dann rumwüten, ist es einfach so, dass dein irgendwie übers WLAN angeschlossene Rechner in deinem Zuhause sind, einfach nicht mehr so zu betrachten, als wenn sie isoliert stünden. Also du musst eh aufpassen, dass das nicht mehr dein privates Netzwerk ist und jeder, der da drin irgendwie seinen Fuß in der Tür hat, kann auch schauen, welcher Traffic da abgeht. Das ist jetzt alles nicht so schlimm, finde ich. Man muss sich nur bewusst werden, dass die Zeit, wo dein einzelner PC dort eine Verbindung mit Mode, mit dem Internet hat, die ist vorbei. Inzwischen kann man sich in deinem Heimnetzwerk so an ziemlich vielen Punkten auch bequem machen. Aber der Router ist schon noch an einer etwas exponierteren Stelle, weil du ihn ja meistens danach fragst, wenn du mal DNS, also Internetadressen aufgelöst haben möchtest, dann ist der DNS Server meistens dein Router. Und dann weiß der, egal wie du da verschlüsselte Verbindungen machst oder nicht, weißt zumindest dein Router, auf welchen Webseiten du dich rumgetrieben hast. Egal was jetzt dein Firefox oder dein Chrome, in welchem Modus du dich da bewegt hast.
Das ist halt das Gerät, das dir dein Internet zu Hause liefert. Und das ist an genau der Stelle, an der man einhaken kann, um dir irgendwelche Antworten zu geben, die jetzt nicht das Internet sind, sondern ja.
Und vor allem du merkst es nicht. Also keine Firewall, kein Antivirus-Programm, irgendwas im Heimnetzwerk kann das detaktieren, weil das halt der Knotenpunkt ist. Das ist das Gateway zum Internet. Das ist die einzige Stelle, wo der ganze Traffic rübergeht.
Ja klar, also deshalb hab ich bei mir zu Hause zum Beispiel auch eine Fritzbox angeklemmt und hab den Speedfall-Router einfach mal, um halt zumindest etwas sicherer zu gehen und weil die Fritzbox noch ein bisschen mehr bietet. Wobei, so hat der Freund schon gesagt, diese Maligations-Telefonen jetzt auch gerade eben zum Thema so DNS und so. Ich hab's dann irgendwann so gemacht, bei mir ging das nämlich dann auch irgendwann auf den Keg. Ich hab dann irgendwann noch mal im eigenen Server einfach ein Bind-DNS-Server installiert und hab dann da einfach mein eigenes Zeug eingestellt und hab dann gar nicht mehr überhaupt die DNS-Server von der Telekom.
Bietet die Fritzbox denn eigentlich wirklich mehr oder macht die nur den Eindruck, als würde sie mehr bieten, weil man mehr drauf rumklicken muss?
Also ich find's zu meinen, finde ich, dass das Interface von der Fritzbox ein bisschen leichter ist und du bekommst nicht angezeigt. Zum Beispiel, ich benutze jetzt Mac OS und wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung hab, als ich da auf diesen Sweeper-Router draufgegangen bin von der Telekom, hieß es dann schon wegen, ja, ich würde einen nicht so schützten Browser verwenden, sozusagen Nutzung auf eigenes Risiko. Das hab ich bei der Fritzbox zumindest mal nicht. Und dann hat die Fritzbox halt natürlich auch ein paar nette Funktionen, so zum Beispiel eben was zum Beispiel das WLAN angeht, dass man eben schauen kann, okay, welcher Kanal kann ich mir jetzt irgendwie, welchen kann ich mir selbst raussuchen, wo ist jetzt irgendwie, hat der Nachbar noch irgendwie drauf, wo kann ich wieder am besten senden. Und dann hat die Fritzbox ja noch verschiedene Funktionen, dass man eben sagen kann, okay, man weiß irgendwie immer so wöchentlich irgendwie eine Statistik haben, wie viel Traffic irgendwie angefallen ist, wo man überall so hinterfoniert hat und so.
Also sie bieten tatsächlich.
Dass man das dann vielleicht mal irgendwie so vergleichen kann mit der Rechnung, die man dann irgendwie am Ende bekommt. Beispielsweise unter einem Buch.
Das ist tatsächlich das Einzige, worüber sich diese Router differenzieren, weil unter der Haube läuft halt dieselbe Software drunter. Das ist, wie groß, das ist alles Linux. Es gibt ein paar wenige Geräte, auf denen vielleicht VXWorks läuft, weil man sich den Flash sparen wollte und nicht so viele Funktionen braucht. Aber im Prinzip ist das alles tatsächlich auch freie Software. Nur gibt es gerade bei besagter Box zum Beispiel das Problem, dass diese Unternehmen sich da halt bedienen und sich so zu hin frickeln. Das hat funktioniert. Aber zum einen die Veränderungen, die sie da machen, nicht an die Community zurückgeben. Oder nur, nachdem man sie ganz doll angepeakt hat, und da ist auch juristisch.
Da muss man dazu sagen, dass diese Software ursprünglich unter einer Lizenz veröffentlicht worden ist, die genau das von einem fordert, wenn man sie kommerziell verwendet, mindestens, dass dort alle Weiterentwicklungen wieder zurückgegeben werden. Steht da eine Lizenz drinnen und da gibt es auch befreundete Anwälte, die sich da das zur Aufgabe gemacht haben, diese Lizenz, diese GPL dort auch durchzusetzen.
Da kann man von leben wahrscheinlich, ne?
Als Anwalt?
Ja, Anwaltfragen ja eben. Robin, schönen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Danke.
Trigger Happy Finger hier.
Ja, ist tatsächlich so, weil in dem Moment, wo so ein Hersteller einen Bug fixt, was sie eh selten tun, die fricken sich meist nur so hin, dass es gerade funktioniert. Da kann vielleicht Mirko ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen, weil die Router differenzieren sich.
Weil der hat es kaputt gemacht.
Ja, also man kann auf jeden Fall den Fokus darauf legen, wie oft Hersteller Updates rausgeben für Router. Also das Verhältnis ist eh ziemlich krass, wenn man sich jetzt überlegt, dass zum Beispiel 500 verschiedene Hardware-Modelle im Feld sind, dann kann man sagen, dass vielleicht das Doppelte oder höchstens das Dreivoran unterschiedlichen Softwareversionen für diese Router existiert. Das heißt, pro Router werden im Durchschnitt höchstens zwei bis drei Updates durchgegeben oder maximal.
Wenn überhaupt, also es gibt Router, die irgendwie mit der Software ausgeliefert werden und das war's dann und dann gibt es wieder welche, wo für die es drei, vier oder fünf, aber das ist die Minderszahl.
Aber am Ende muss man sich vorstellen, dass dieses, genau dieses Betriebssystem, was da ständig Meldungen hat, dass da dieses Programm und dieses Programm Fehler hat, um einen beliebigen Code darauf auszuführen, dass dieses Betriebssystem, was ja eigentlich schon im Internet ständig man hinterherpatchen muss und dass dort ziemlich viele bezahlte Leute in großen Firmen ständig dabei sind, alle Fehler zu korrigieren und die dann im Wochentakt neu zu machen. Und genau sowas hat man da eigentlich auch am Internet. Das heißt, man stellt sie zu Hause hin, man hat eine öffentliche IP-Adresse und es damit aus dem Internet zu erreichen. Und es gibt auch Leute, die sich dann so als Sport mal eingerichtet haben, das gesamte Internet abzugrasen und mal nachzugucken, wer da lauscht, wer da guckt. Und im Optimalfall rauszufinden, genau welche Version von welchem kleinen Plast-Router mit welcher Software das da drauf ist.
Und wenn man dann einmal so einen Fehler gefunden hat, den man ausnutzen kann, dann hat man ein Jackpot, weil es gibt halt nicht nur eine von diesen Boxen, sondern ein paar Hunderttausende. Und ja.
Es gab ein Projekt von Leuten, die wollten das gesamte Internet einmal scannen und konnten das natürlich nicht mit einem oder zwei Rechnern machen, auch nicht mit Hunderten oder Tausenden. Und haben sich deswegen bestimmte Router ausgesucht, die halt Sicherheitslücken hatten und haben die missbraucht, um halt Teile des Internets zu scannen und die Statistiken dann halt an einen zentralen Server zu senden. Und somit haben sie es wirklich geschafft, mit Hilfe von Zehntausenden von Routern, die halt zu Hause stehen, das Internet abzugrasen. Und das war halt noch ein sehr humaner Fall. Sie haben die Bandbreite limitiert. Sie haben keine Rückstände auf den Routern zurückgelassen. Aber sie hätten halt durchaus Schadcode auf die Router laden können. Und mit Sicherheit, man weiß, dass auf den meisten oder echt vielen Routern Schadcode ist, die halt die Router zu einem Teil von einem Botnetz machen.
Na ja, das heißt auf den meisten Routern. Aber man kann mit Sicherheit davon ausgehen, dass in so ziemlich allen Routern, die da derzeit deployed sind, mindestens eine kritische Sicherheitslücke existiert, die sowas ermöglicht.
Kann ich das dann sehen als User? Also als Ich-User, nicht als User.
Das ist ja genau das, was man als Botnetz-Betreiber möchte, dass du das genau nicht siehst. Also du merkst dann vielleicht, deine Box wird ein bisschen heiß, aber so ein Botnetz funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn der Bot lange genug funktioniert und wenn dem Benutzer das nicht auffällt. Also es sind die besten Bots, die lange überleben auf dem Gerät. Im Fall von diesem Cana Botnet war es tatsächlich sogar so, dass der keine Daten auf dem Gerät verändert hat, sondern nur im Rahmen gelaufen ist, weil auf Überwachungskameras und Industriesteuerungen hast du nicht gesehen, da brauchst du dich nicht speichern. Das ist zum einen noch mal ein anderer Level, was so die Bösartigkeit angeht und auch die Gefahr, dass ein Gerät dadurch kaputt geht. Das wollten sie natürlich nicht. Und eben nicht auffallen, dass das Gerät nicht neu gestartet wird und der Bot wieder weg ist.
Sie haben es dann Volkszählung, also Tensus 2013 genannt, was ziemlich nett der Name für das Projekt ist.
Haben wir denn interessante Daten dabei rausgefunden? Ist es irgendwie als Arzt genutzt oder hat es nur Spaß gemacht?
420 Millionen aktive Rechner im Internet gefunden, also die auf Pinks geantwortet haben und entsprechend online waren.
Alleine diese Zahl zu wissen, ist schon geil irgendwie.
Ja, weiß man zwar auch nicht, wie so eine Zahl, die dann einfach, muss man doch mal ausrechnen, wie viel das in Kilogramm oder in China-Containern oder... Genau.
Wie viele iPads das sind. 24 Millionen vermutlich.
Auf deiner Seite, wenn man sich überlegt, 420 Millionen mal dein DSL, lass die irgendwie alle mit 384 Kilobit angebunden sein im Schnitt, macht schon ordentlich Bums. Wenn man die alle auf seiner Seite hat und dann mal jemanden ärgern möchte, dann macht das schon Bums. Da kann man schon irgendwie so ein größeres Ziel mal aus dem Netz befördern.
Die 9.01 Spammer. Chaosradio, 188, es geht uns um Ruta heute Abend.
Der Nibbler, der Mörk und der Erdreiß sind im Studio und die 0331 70 97 160 angerufen hat der Nicky.
Hallo Nicky. Die Nicky, verdammt.
Hallo die Nicky.
Ja.
Ich hatte angerufen, weil vorhin ja die Frage war, welche so die schlimmsten Kunden sind, die angerufen haben.
Du arbeitest an einer Hotline.
Ich habe gearbeitet ja eine ganze Weile, zwei Jahre lang.
Bei wem?
Bei der Telekom als technischer Support.
Muss man dafür eigentlich was können oder habt ihr auch als technischer Support ein Protokoll, das ihr abarbeitet?
Wir haben auch ein Protokoll da. Das ist quasi eine Arbeitsanweisung, was wir zu machen haben und was nicht quasi.
Ach ja, da steht auch, was ihr nicht zu machen habt?
Es sind halt solche Sachen, wenn das und das Problem dann leite, an den und den weiter und wenn das und das dann an den und den und so.
Das heißt selbst wenn du genügend Sachverstand hättest, das Problem zu lösen, darfst du es nicht?
Teilweise ja, weil es dann halt auf die Anrufzeit geht.
Ach du hast doch nur eine bestimmte Zeit, die du mit den Leuten reden darfst?
So theoretisch gesehen ja, man hat dann so seine Normwerte, die und die Zeit sollte es nicht überschreiten und wenn man dann irgendwie zwei Stunden mit dem Kunden am machen ist, dann kommen sie an und sagen, du machst jetzt aber schon zwei Stunden, überleg mal, mach mal hinne.
Darfst du dann einfach auflegen?
Nein.
Echt nicht so, Arschloch, klick.
Hallo, ich kann Sie nicht mehr hören, hallo, rufen Sie bitte nochmal an.
Wenn der Kunde, sag ich mal beleidigt wird, dann darf man auflegen, aber sonst muss man immer warten, bis der Kunde auflegt.
Das geht auch in die Statistik mit ein, also zumindest habe ich das in einem Unternehmen mal gesehen, dass das tatsächlich ein Faktor ist, der in die persönliche Bewertung einzieht, die neben der Länge, wie er aufgelegt hat.
Richtig, ja. Das ist tatsächlich auch so.
Super, aber erzähl mal von den Kunden, mit dem spannenden Kram, los.
Ich hatte in den zwei Jahren einige Kunden, die wirklich außerordentlich doof waren, würde ich mal sagen. Einer zum Beispiel hatte angerufen, weil das Internet nicht funktionierte und ich sagte ihm halt so, dann gucken wir mal auf den Router drauf. Welche Leuchten sind denn gerade an oder eben nicht an? Und er sagt, er kann nicht drauf gucken. Da habe ich dann halt gefragt, warum. Ob irgendwie er vom Telefon nicht weg kann oder wie auch immer. Und er sagt, das Haus ist jetzt so ungefähr ein halbes Jahr alt. Und als ich das gebaut habe, habe ich halt den Router mit eingemauert.
Da hat jemand Vertrauen ins Produkt.
Ich habe gedacht, ich muss mir erstmal das Headset abnehmen und muss erstmal eine Runde lachen, damit er das nicht mitkriegt. Und ich habe echt gedacht, das ist der Wahnsinn. Kann ja ja sein.
Hallo, Telefon streich den Boden. Was geht denn auf Ihrem Schirm? Knirps.
Ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, dass man sowas, also ich kann mir keine geistige Disposition vorstellen, die dazu führt, dass man seinen Router einmauert.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie er drauf gekommen ist. Keine Ahnung.
Das ist fast wie Zahnbürste einmauern.
Und dann hast du ihm gesagt, dann hol dir ein Stemmeisen und...
Ich hab ihn dann gebeten, dass er sich darum kümmern soll, dass das Ding rauskommt und dann kann er sich gerne wieder melden, wenn es dann noch Probleme gibt.
Setzen Sie sich mal hin. Wie fest ist das denn eingemauert? Wie dick ist denn die Mauer?
In Amerika wärst du verklagt worden dafür. Stand nämlich nicht drauf, dass man das nicht kann.
In Amerika wurdest du einfach mit der Faust durch die Wand, weil das ist nicht weit und danach wieder zumacht. Da stellt sich das Problem nicht.
Das war so einer der schlimmsten, die ich hatte, aber es gab noch viele andere.
Hat er denn verstanden, was das Problem ist, als du dann genug gelacht hattest und gesagt hast, ja pass mal auf, hat er das kapiert oder hat er gedacht?
Nach einigen diskutieren hat er es dann eingesehen, dass wir schon wissen müssten, was mit dem Rute eigentlich los ist und dass wenn er getauscht werden muss, er dann sowieso raus müsste. Das hat er dann irgendwie schon, aber ich muss ihn davon überzeugen.
Ich meine, das war ja wahrscheinlich auch so ein Telekom-Router. Die sehen ja schon so aus, als würden sie zügig kaputt gehen. So was mauer ich doch nicht ein. Ich meine, wenn das Ding irgendwie aus, aus irgendwie, aus dem Augen, aus dem Kopf, aus dem V2A irgendwie stahl.
Oder das Züchselmodium noch.
Ja genau und mit so tierisch dicken Goldanschlüssen oder irgendwie sowas, dann würde ich sagen, aus dem Augen, aus dem Sinn.
Vielleicht wollt ihr einfach so dieses Plasteding da nicht im Zimmer stehen haben, kann ich auch nachvollziehen.
Ja natürlich kann ich auch, aber dann mache ich eine Aussparung in der, naja, da brauchen wir nicht drüber zu reden.
Ja das war so einer der interessantesten, die ich da überhaupt dabei hatte. Also den werde ich wahrscheinlich auch meinen restlichen Leben nicht vergessen, weil der einfach so bescheuert war.
Was sind denn die angenehmsten eigentlich? Wie kann man euch hotline leuten? Weil ihr seid ja eigentlich die armen Schweine, die da irgendwie in vorderster Front stehen und immer erst zuerst abkriegen. Wie kann man euch denn eigentlich eine Freude machen?
Vermutlich nicht anrufen.
Oder das Protokoll schon kennen und die ganzen Antworten geben.
Ansonsten war es immer hilfreich, wenn die Leute Ahnung hatten auf jeden Fall. Und dann von vornherein sagen konnten, okay das hat er gemacht, das war schon mal eine große Hilfe. Oder wenn man einfach freundlich war und das gemacht hat, was man ihm gesagt hat. Da gab es dann auch viele, wo man dann sagt, okay dann gehen sie mal in den Rechner, probieren das und das mal aus. Und dann sagt er dann auf einmal, ja ich habe aber jetzt das, das, das, das gemacht. Und du denkst, ja dann fangen wir jetzt nochmal von vorn an, dann machen sie das, das, das, das.
Dann fassen sie jetzt mal die beiden Kabel an, die da aus der Wand kommen.
Entweder man hat Ahnung oder man hält einfach den Mund und macht, was gesagt wird. Gut.
Ist das ein guter Job oder ist das ein schlimmer Job?
Stress? Im Call Center hat man ja viel Stress durch die vielen Anrufe, aber normalerweise fände ich es eigentlich von der Arbeit her in sich ganz in Ordnung.
Das ist ja abwechslungsreich. Weil jedes Mal, wenn das Telefon klingelt und man jemand dran hat, weiß man noch nicht, wo es hin und her geht.
Das ist wie so eine Hörertalk Sendung hier.
Und was natürlich hilfreich ist auch, wenn man Leute spricht, die auch wirklich Deutsch reden und wissen, wovon man redet. Das hatte ich nämlich auch öfter, dass dann die türkische Mutter angerufen hat mit ihren drei Kindern und die gingen ihr tierisch auf die Sackweise kein Fernsehen gucken wollen, weil das entertainment lief und sie konnten mir überhaupt nicht sagen, was überhaupt die Sache ist.
Das ist vielleicht auch nicht eine Frage der ethnischen oder der sprachlichen, sondern dass man einfach irgendwo auf einem Level ist und das, was man rüberbringt, auf der anderen Seite ankommt und umgekehrt.
Das ist natürlich klar. Nur wenn es dann eben so weit ist, dass wirklich nur ein Bröckchen Deutsch verstanden oder gesprochen wird, dann ist das halt schwierig. Ich kann ja nicht jede Sprache der Welt.
Habt ihr da nicht einen solchen Mitarbeiter für? Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass in einem großen Unternehmen man jetzt schon für irgendwie Deutsch, Englisch klar, vielleicht Türkisch, vielleicht Französisch. Spanisch. Das darf schon so die Spanisch die häufigsten Fälle sein.
Es gab oder es gibt auch nach wie vor Hotlines direkt für russische Leute. Ich glaube, es war russisch, türkisch, polnisch glaube ich auch und Englisch.
Aber das ist das ist in den normalen Hotline Prozessen nicht drin, dass du sagst, okay, sprich türkisch, ich leite sofort weiter. Das heißt, du hast nur noch die Wahl, irgendwelche Kommandos zu bellen, in der Hoffnung, dass derjenige, der kaum Deutsch spricht, wenigstens den Befehl versteht.
Lüttven Reset. Internet Jock.
Nicky, wir danken für deinen Anruf.
Gute Nacht, Tschüss.
Telefon zu Pirtual.
Nein, das war genau die fünf Worte Türkisch.
Verstehe.
Chaos Radio 188, die Musik kommt immer noch von Kirill Sergeyev zu finden auf mixotic.net. Und es ist das Mix tape Nummer 48. Was ist da ist Chaos Radio 188 beschäftigt sich mit Routern. Ich hab jetzt Angst, weil meine Fritzbox ist heiß.
Eine Plast-Router.
Plast-Router, Verzeihung. Meine Fritzbox ist heiß und eben habt ihr gesagt, da könnte ja jetzt durchaus auch so ein Bot, das könnte ja Teil eines Botnetzes sein, dass jemand meine Fritzbox übernommen hat. Wie finde ich denn raus, ob das so ist?
Der einfachste Weg ist einfach nicht rausfinden, sondern einfach wieder neu machen.
Neue Fritzbox kaufen?
Ne, neue Firmware drauf. Ist ja irgendwie eigentlich was immer so, auch der Tipp ist, wenn dein Zuhause-Rechner infiziert ist, einfach mach noch ein Backup von den wichtigsten Daten und danach setzten neu auf und bei so einem Router ist es ja nun nicht ganz so doll schwer, weil es ja nun nicht so viel Flash drinne und dann...
Immer wieder Zeit für ein Firmware-Update.
Genau. Aber da du ja da eh nur über das Netz drauf zugreifen kannst, ist es halt ein bisschen blöd, weil der könnte dir einfach vortäuschen. Naja, ich hab die neue Firmware da jetzt grad eingespielt, ist alles in Ordnung. Also ist auch nicht so...
Das heißt eigentlich hab ich keine Chance.
Du kannst dich zwischen deinem Router und deiner Telefondose stecken und den Traffic mitsniffen und gucken, ob dort irgendwas ungewöhnliches ist. Aber das ist bestimmt die nette wenigsten.
Das könnte man bestimmt als Dienstleistung anbieten. Das Problem ist ja immer, dass so Typen wie ich, die verstehen halt, was das Problem ist, aber sind zu doof eine Lösung, sich irgendwie einfallen zu lassen oder die vorhandenen Lösungen zu benutzen. Und ich glaube, so Typen, wenn du an solche Leute rangehst...
Wie Netzkammerjäger.
Ja, sowas. Ich wäre halt auch bereit, und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das sehr viele sind, dafür sogar Geld zu bezahlen, dass jemand kommt, dem ich vertraue, der guckt und sagt, nee, ist in Ordnung.
Kann ich machen. Ich komm vorbei, sag, ist in Ordnung. Aber natürlich kann man ja versuchen zu verhindern, dass sich überhaupt Software auf deinem Rechner oder auf deinem Plastirouter da einnistet, indem du einfach eine eigene außergewöhnliche Distribution da einspielst. Indem du da einfach was aus dem Internet, da gibt es ja auch inzwischen was von Rationfarben für viele gängige Router, und dann fährst du halt zum Beispiel ein Open VRT drauf oder so ein NetBSD. Da gab es auch so ein Monowall.
Aber da habe ich ja dann wieder das Problem, dass ich das überhaupt nicht mehr verstehe, oder? Oder ist das auch so clicky bundy für Dove?
Das ist inzwischen auch schon fast clicky bundy für Dove. Wäre aber auch mal eine schöne Möglichkeit jetzt für dich, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, zu gucken, was da so im Kern dir zu Hause Internet macht. Das ist so, glaube ich, inzwischen so Haushaltsgrundlagenwissen, denke ich mal, sollte man für den Internetführer scheiden. So grob zu wissen, was es ist, was einem Internet macht.
Zumindest für die Gewichtsklasse B.
Das Internet hat zum Beispiel OpenWrt, also eine freie Linux-Distribution für Router, Router. Läuft auf wirklich vieler Hardware und vielen Gateways und Routern, die zu Hause stehen. Und da kann man sich ruhig einfach mal informieren. Da gibt es halt Auflistungen von Hardware, wo das drauf laufen könnte und entsprechend die alternative Firmware installieren.
Wie viele gibt es denn da so gerade? Wie viele verschiedene offene Firmware-Projekte für so Plast-Router und auf wie viele verschiedene Plast-Router laufen die? Läuft dann alles auf eben oder?
Nee, also die Hersteller, die ändern ja auch immer ihre Hardware und von daher wird es schwer. Also es muss halt portiert werden. Es muss halt initial einmal OpenWrt auf dieser Box portiert werden. Da sich aber die Hardware nur marginal unterscheidet, meistens ist es relativ einfach. Und OpenWrt läuft auf geschätzt 100, 200 Routern unterschiedlichen Modellen.
Du siehst du Holgi.
Da hab ich ja was zu tun.
Läuft das noch auf allen Fritz-Boxen, dieses OpenWrt?
Leider nicht. Nicht? Weil die Fritz-Boxen teilweise Chips drin haben, wie zum Beispiel von Broadcom, die keine offenen Quellsourcen für ihre Chips bereitstellen. Und das leider sehr schwierig ist, dort den Support drauf zu portieren.
Aber die verwenden doch da auch so einen Linux. Warum können die das anpassen, ohne die Quellen zurückgeben zu müssen?
Das ist wie immer dieser GPL-Streit. Die GPL sollte eigentlich vorsehen, dass sie die Sourcen bereitstellen sollen. Allerdings versuchen sie, sich daraus zu winden, mit irgendwelchen Argumentationen, die teilweise als valide, teilweise nicht angesehen wären. Und das sind halt immer Rechtsstreitereien.
Nein, das heißt, ich kann mir vorstellen, dass die vor Gericht sagen, ja, hier GPL interessiert uns nicht, gucken Sie, Herr Richter, da, Fritz Box, das ist kein Computer, da ist kein Monitor, keine Tastatur dran, da Lizenz, Software.
Das ist kein Scherz, das haben sie wirklich gebracht.
Das ist kein Computer, sonst könnt ihr Schach spielen. Wir machen Nachrichten, danach ist Chaosradio 188 wieder da, um Ruta geht's heute.
Also ich persönlich finde Fritz ja ganz unmöglich, so etwas wie Fritz in meinem schönen Nordkorea, wenn da jeder seine eigene Meinung sagen könnte und die Leute so richtige, echte Informationen kriegen würden.
Und dazu noch diese rebellische Musik.
Da wäre ich ja die längste Zeit Diktator, Staatsoberhaupt gewesen.
Außerdem kenne ich doch mein Volk.
Meine Nordkoreaner werden viel zu gern unterdrückt.
Da macht so was wie Rundfunkbeitrag für unabhängige Medien gar keinen Sinn, wa?
Fritz, unabhängig durch euren Rundfunkbeitrag.
In Italien ist die Bildung einer neuen Regierung gescheitert. Die Sondierungsgespräche des Linkspolitikers Pierluigi Bersani mit den anderen Parteien waren nicht erfolgreich. Das hat Bersani am Abend Italiens Staatspräsident Napolitano mitgeteilt. Die Regierungsbildung ist schwierig, weil aus der Wahl Ende Februar drei nahezu gleich starke Lager hervorgegangen waren, ohne dass es einen eindeutigen Sieger gab. Journalisten, die für den Münchner NSU-Prozess zugelassen sind, dürfen ihren Platz jetzt doch mit anderen Reportern tauschen. Das hat das Oberlandesgericht München entschieden. Bei der Vergabe der 50 festen Plätze waren Journalisten von türkischen Medien leer ausgegangen, obwohl die meisten Opfer der Neonazi-Mordserie einen türkischen Migrationshintergrund hatten. Dies hatte im In- und Ausland scharfen Protest ausgelöst. Grundsätzlich, so das Münchner Gericht, bleibe es jedoch bei der Akkreditierungsliste. Sie werde nicht erweitert. Drei Raumfahrer sind von einem Weltraumbahnhof in Kasachstan zu einem Rekordflug ins All gestartet. Die beiden Russen und ein Amerikaner wollen innerhalb von sechs Stunden, also noch in der Nacht, die internationale Raumstation ISS erreichen. Bislang waren für so eine Reise zwei Tage nötig. Das neue Sechs-Stunden-Schema wurde möglich, da der digitale Bordcomputer nun unabhängig vom Flugleitzentrum arbeitet. Ein ständiger Funkkontakt mit dem Boden ist nicht mehr nötig. In Lübbenau sollen ab dem Jahr 2016 die vier Bahnübergänge verschwinden. Bahn, Land, Kreis und Stadt haben eine Kreuzungsvereinbarung unterschrieben, mit der die Verkehrsprobleme gelöst werden sollen. Knapp 27 Millionen Euro werden dafür in der Spreewaldstadt investiert. Die Eisbären Berlin haben das fünfte Playoff-Viertelfinal-Spiel gegen die Hamburg Freezers gewonnen. Zuhause gab's am Abend einen 3 zu 2-Sieg. Damit steht's in der Serie Best of Seven 3 zu 2 für die Eisbären. Wenn die Eisbären noch das nächste Spiel am Samstag gewinnen, sind sie weiter. In der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga hat Energie Cottbus zuhause gegen den VFR Ahlen gespielt. Die Partie endete unentschieden 1 zu 1. In Berlin Tiergarten 0 Grad, in Friedrichshain minus 1 Grad. Netzeband und Eberswalde minus 1 Grad. Brück und Cottbus 0 Grad. In der Nacht soll es wieder schneien, vor allem im Süden. Die Temperaturen können sinken auf bis minus 4 Grad. Uns steht wohl weiße Ostern bevor. Das Wochenende bleibt wolkig, immer wieder schneit es in ganz Berlin und Brandenburg. Tagsüber morgen gibt es maximal plus 5 Grad. Autobahn 2 Magdeburg Richtung Berlin. Es gibt Stau zwischen Wollin und Dreieck Werder. Autobahn 10 Südlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Schönefelder Kreuz. Es gibt Stau zwischen Dreieck Werder und Dreieck Potsdam. Autobahn 12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt. Zwischen Biegener Hellen und Frankfurt West gibt es einen Lkw-Stau in Richtung Polen. Bundesstraße 96, der Tunnel Tiergarten in Berlin, ist wegen Wartungsarbeiten vom Reich Piedschufer bis zur Heidestraße gesperrt. Und bei der Berliner S-Bahn fahren die Züge der Linie S1 bis Sonntag Betriebsschluss nicht. Zwischen Wannsee und Sundgauer Straße, hier sind Busse im Einsatz. Gute Fahrt.
Danke Philipp, sechs Minuten nach halb zwölf.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr Fritz als App auf eurem Handy wollt, dann holt euch jetzt die Fritz App. Kostenlos jetzt in eure Google Play und App.
Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Chaos Radio 188 ist hier. Wir reden über Router.
Sozusagen der digitale Bordcomputer zu Hause.
Aber cool, ich hätte auch gedacht, dass wir längst aus den Nachrichten gerade haben was gehört, dass wir jetzt nicht mehr so lange zur ISS fliegen. Also wir können mittlerweile innerhalb 6 Stunden zur ISS fliegen, weil die Rakete sich selbst rechnet.
Ich dachte, die hätten da schon eh immer so noch ein Computer mit an Bord, der irgendwie guckt wie...
Ja, aber der war analog.
Also analoger Bordcomputer? Genau, analoger Bordcomputer mit Röhren.
Röhrkarten, Röhren und so. Tierisch stromgefressen, das scheiß Ding. Also diese riesigen Raketen, also diese riesigen Triebwerke, also diese Tanks.
Die waren eigentlich nur um die Konkrete her.
Wie die Standheizung, so musst du dir das vorstellen.
Aber irgendwie statt zwei Tagen jetzt in sechs Stunden und alles macht der Computer an Bord, what could possibly go wrong?
Ist geil, aber da kann man endlich mal zum Urlaub hochfliegen. Ich meine, sechs Stunden, hä?
Franz Faz geht das immer so.
Ich meine, zwei Tage weg kriegt man zu viel Urlaub, aber ich meine, sechs Stunden ist doch mal ein schöner Daytrip.
Ja, das kannst du so, einmal Krankenschein holen und ab.
Wo kann man das schreiben?
Aber hat eigentlich schon jemand versucht, oder daran gedacht sicherlich, aber hat schon mal jemand versucht, eigentlich aus all den Routern, die so rumstehen, ein eigenes Internet zu bauen? Also eigentlich wäre das doch möglich. Ich müsste doch im Grunde nur genug Router, die nah genug beieinander stehen, irgendwie miteinander.
Du meinst, so per WLAN versuchen, so zu meschen.
Das finde ich ja mal ein interessantes Experiment.
Ja, da gab es schon, also das war doch nicht so ein eigenes Internet, aber es ist so...
Das ist halt ein LAN.
Siehst du wie Berlin Rufnet oder so?
Ja, es gibt auch Freifunk als Initiative.
Ja, die versuchen einfach wirklich...
Aber die Freifunker machen doch, die machen nur Internet.
Ja, die meschen sich auch und das Internet geht dann bei allen, die da eine DSL-Leitung oder vielleicht noch eine analoge Leitung haben, aber zumindest, wenn wir dann ans richtige Internet angeschlossen sind, geht es dann an mehreren Punkten da rein und wird dann über WLAN verteilt. Das gibt es schon, ja.
Störerhaftung jetzt wieder, ne?
Störerhaftung, so ein Reizwort.
Reizwort Störerhaftung. Kommen wir zurück zu den Sachen ohne Reizwörter.
Aber es gab diesen Fall, wo DSL Modems sich gegenseitig gesehen haben, sodass ich als einziger Rechner hinter meinem DSL Modem irgendwie Samba und Windows Shares gesehen hab, weil meine Nachbarn am selben D-Slam, also an derselben Büchse am Straßenrand angeschlossen waren. Genau, und dann ein großes Intranet existierte.
Das war aber Zufall, oder? Das war nicht zu gehört.
Das war nicht gewollt, nein. Ich war es nicht.
Nee, aber es ist tatsächlich auch eine deutsche Eigenheit, dass hier so PPPUE gesprochen wird, also dass man über diese Verbindung, die man zu seinem Provider hat, noch mal eine Verbindung aufbaut, um ins Internet zu kommen.
Das hab ich nie verstanden.
Mir ist ganz einfach. Das muss irgendwo in deren Infrastruktur und in deren Prozesse reinpassen. Du hast dich vorher auch mit deinem analogen Modem und mit ESDN via PPP eingewählt.
Ja, eben, das ist ja so Teil ab.
Und das haben sie eins zu eins umgesetzt, weil da kannst du auch über eine Anbindung zu mehreren Anbietern kommen. Also kannst du einen PPP-Account bei der Telekom haben. Du kannst einen bei deinem kleinen Hinterhof-ISP haben, der dann von der Telekom zum Beispiel die Vorleistung bezieht. PPP und so weiter. Das nennt sich ZISP. Das heißt, die Telekom gibt dem dann die Verbindungen weiter, die die Kunden aufbauen. Sprich, du baust deine PPP-Verbindung über dein DSL Modem auf und bekommst dann nicht Pakete von der Telekom, sondern von diesem Anbieter. Das ist also ein Feature dieser feinen, granularen Reseller-Struktur. Du kannst als anderer Anbieter aber auch dir entweder nur den blanken Draht, das kostet um den Zehner im Monat, von der Telekom kaufen, musst dann aber dein eigenes Equipment in die Vermittlungsstelle stellen oder in den Outdoor-Di-Slam. Gibt auch noch diverse Mischformen dazwischen, die dann unterschiedlich anders funktionieren. In anderen Ländern hast du einfach Internet, wenn das Ding ran, ohne irgendwie Zugangsdaten, sondern da liegt halt auf deinem Port Internet. Da brauchst du dich nicht mehr einwählen oder irgendwo eine Verbindung zu einem PPC aufbauen, sondern da, ja.
So weiß ich das wenigstens auch mal.
Aber hast du zumindest dein Gefühl, dass ich nicht getrübt ist?
Ja, das kam mir irgendwie komisch vor, weil, ja.
Das ist schon ein bisschen wirr. Ich hab ja bei mir zu Hause auch versucht, das über dieselbe Netzwerkkarte da hinzubekommen, so sein internes Netzwerk oder sein externes Netzwerk einfach dann auf derselben Netzwerkkarte abzufeiern, oder wie PPPoE darauf zu sprechen. Da raten sie einem aber auch immer von ab. Und aus gutem Grund, weil, naja, das wird jetzt zu technisch.
Sollten zwar Fehler da sein, aber kann man sich nicht wirklich drauf verlassen.
Kann ruhig technisch werden. Es hören ja nicht nur so Schwachsinnige wie ich so zu, sondern auch Leute, die das verstehen.
Und im Fall von Kabel ist das tatsächlich auch so. So DOCSIS, das Kabelprotokoll, da sieht man schon das öfteren andere Teilnehmer und fremder, fremder Leute, Datagrams auf dem Port. Also da will man eigentlich schon so ein Plastorouter dazwischen hängen.
Du kannst also gucken, was deine Nachbarn klicken, ohne in deren WLAN unterwegs zu sein. Finde ich aber auch nur zu gerecht, wenn die blöden Puppe einfach ihre WLANs alle zu machen, dann muss man halt woanders lang. Dann muss man, ja, ja. Aber es ist ja sowieso diese WLAN-Benennung, da gibt es ja immer so die Leute, die da einfach so neben in die Ecke stellen, anschalten und das beibehalten.
Kauft ihr selber WLAN, hab ich mal, nee, kauft ihr selber Internet, hab ich mal an einem WLAN gesehen.
Ja, ich hab mal gesehen, wir können euch poppen hören. Ja, und inzwischen möchte ja auch Google, dass man seinen WLAN noch umbenennt, wenn man nicht von denen erfasst werden möchte. Die fahren mit diesen Autos rum und gucken, welche Ideas dagegen blasen. Und wenn man nicht möchte, dass die Geokoordinate mit seiner WLAN-ID verbunden ist, dann soll man hinten noch so ein Unterstrich-Nom-Map dranhängen. Das muss man sich selber opt outen.
Wusste ich aber jetzt auch nicht, dass ich das hätte tun müssen, wenn ich das nicht gewollt hätte.
Da die Pläne auslagen in Alpha Ventauri.
Ja, na gut, dann.
Und wenn du nicht nachguckst, aber finde ich auch schon ein bisschen dreist, dass die da hergehen und sagen, benennen doch mal bitte dein Netz um, damit wir nicht mitschneiden, wo du zu Hause bist.
Ja, wenn du der stärkste Junge in der Klasse bist, dann kannst du sowas erlauben. Der Lukas hat angerufen, Name Lukas.
Du hast gesagt, so eigene Netze bauen. Gerade eben. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch der Begriff Packet Radio noch bekannt ist.
Ja, finde ich super romantisch irgendwie. Hab ich mir schon mal angeguckt, was man da für Equipment für braucht, weil ich das so romantisch fand und hab dann gedacht, oh nee, das verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch, ich meine, das war so 1K2, 9K6. Das ist ja auch nur ein bisschen lange her.
Ja, aber aus apokalyptischer Sicht ist das halt total geil, Packet Radio.
Das ist da der Weg, du lernst dabei, was geht dir ja nicht darum, irgendwie in Zweifel, wenn die Welt untergeht.
Ich wollte eigentlich damit nur einleiten zu, naja, man könnte sagen, Packet Radio 2.0. Nein, heutzutage nennt man das Hemnet und es baut tatsächlich auch WLAN-Hardware auf. Es ist ein eigenes Netzwerk, komplett im 44 Punkt und so weiter, IPv4 halt.
Ist das dann so richtig WLAN-Hardware, was ich dir unterbrechen darf, oder spricht dir da ein eigenes Protokoll?
Das ist einfach nur IP, ganz normal. Es ist im Prinzip, man könnte sagen wie Internet, BGP. Das sind überwiegend von Mikrotik oder Ubiquiti.
Und wie sprechen die da miteinander? Über wie lang?
Über wie lang, genau.
Und das ad hoc oder was ist denn da wo du bist?
Nee, nee, das ist richtig schon so wie sonst auch. Also Access Point und Client und dann werden halt Linksstrecken aufgebaut. Also ich komme aus Osnabrück, hier gibt es halt auf dem Uni-Gebäude gibt es halt einen Link ins Internet und von daraus geht es dann weiter auf dem Funk-Turm, also aus dem Fernmeldeturm hier in Osnabrück. Von da aus geht es weiter nach Bielefeld auf einen ja einen kleineren Turm, der direkt neben dem Fernmeldeturm steht.
Jetzt hast du dich aber verraten, Bielefeld gibt es doch gar nicht. Ja, also ist es wie Freifunk nur in strukturiert und mit BEP und so weiter verschieben.
Also wie Freifunk, nur Freifunk ist ja mehr Mesh und bei uns ist es strukturiert und organisiert und halt ja gut Amateurfunk, automatische Arbeiten in Stationen, also sprich mit Genehmigungen, mit Lizenzen dabei.
Preisfrage, wenn du sagst irgendwie Amateurfunk und Funk-Amateure werden dann die Daten nach Plane übertragen, darf man verschlüsseln, darf man darüber HTTPS und so weiter machen?
Genau, das ist so ein bisschen ein Problem. Man darf nicht verschlüsseln. Also streng genommen darf man auch nicht mal, wenn man da irgendwo ein Passwort überträgt, um sich auf so einer Kiste einzuloggen, um die zu administrieren, streng genommen darf man auch nicht mal das Passwort verschlüsseln.
Wer verbietet das?
Das ist der Funk-Amateur, das ist der Funk-Amateur an Usos.
Ach so, also alles muss offen sein.
Genau, auf Amateur-Funk darfst du, wenn du jetzt mal von Phonie, also von Sprache ausgehst, du darfst jede Sprache der Welt sprechen und kannst dich damit unterhalten, was du halt nicht darfst, sind irgendwelche verschlüsselnden Geheimsprachen oder so. Und das bezieht sich halt auch auf Daten.
Das ist halt so der Deal dafür, dass es Amateur-Funkbänder gibt, die man als Funkamateur benutzen darf, quasi auch exklusiv. Es ist halt der Deal, dass man das zwar jederzeit benutzen darf, wenn man seine Lizenz hat, aber das dafür im Klartext und auch dazu sagen muss, wer man ist und so weiter. Deswegen hat man ein Rufzeichen.
Dass man sich gar nicht erst heimlich zur Revolution verabreden kann. Funkerspuk, sag ich nur.
Für solche Linksprecken, also 40 km sind noch ganz gut machbar. Das geht zwar mit WLAN-Hardware, aber nicht mit den Mitteln, die ein Standard-Plast-Router mit Standard-Antenne hat, sondern da sind dann schon entsprechende Antennenpanel oder Spiegel nötig und mit entsprechend höheren Sendeleistungen.
Das Schickste ist natürlich, wenn man das als Funkamateur macht, dann darf man natürlich auch auf anderen Bändern als den 2, 4 oder 5, 5 hast du nicht gesehen, sondern da gibt es ja auch Amateur-Bänder in der Region, die man mit entsprechend modifizierter Hardware, was man ja glaube ich machen darf. Weiß ich nicht, wie sieht denn das aus? Fahrt ihr da Strecken, die nicht auf den 802.fab Frequenz brauchen?
Also die genannten Router, also das läuft alles auf 5 Gigahertz. Einfach weil, man kann da zwar basteln, aber das ist preislich einfach, ja.
Aber schwierig dann Antennen zu bekommen, passende und so weiter.
Nicht das Problem, Antennen basteln ist relativ einfach, aber das läuft halt alles auf Standard-WLAN-Hardware und billiger kann man es nicht haben.
Ja gut, aber die Standard-WLAN-Hardware, also gerade ATRs und so weiter, gibt es ja in allen möglichen Frequenzbereichen, auch mit unterschiedlichen Front-Einsatzpro-Kommerziell erhältlich auch irgendwie in 3 Gigahertz.
Also alles in 5 Gigahertz, man aber nicht in den, ja, Stückchen neben den üblichen freigegebenen Sachen. Also man kann mit den Routern, kann man einfach auch so, ohne da jetzt irgendwas dran rumzuhacken, die sind halt so frei, dass du da andere Frequenzen einstellen kannst. Und ja, damit kommt man dann einfach in den Amateurfunk-Bereich, der dann da in der Ecke ist.
Ah, verstehe, also es gibt da einen Amateurfunk-Bereich, einen Frequenzbereich, den man nutzen kann, der auch von so einer Hardware noch gespielt werden kann.
Und man kann auch noch niemals jeden WLAN-Router nehmen. Also zum einen halt nicht jeder WLAN-Router kommt in den Amateurfunk-Bereich. Und zum anderen haben wir da auch eine Bandbreitenbeschränkung drin. Also wir dürfen, was war das eigentlich? 10 MHz, 20 MHz Bandbreite nur machen. Und üblich da oben sind halt wesentlich mehr.
Also wenn man jetzt so guckt, diese ganzen N-Sachen und so, das sind ja mindestens 40 MHz oder so was.
Ja, aber wenn ihr da Ubiquiti-Hardware verwendet, die kann das ja, wenn man irgendwie den Ich Bin Erwachsenen-Button drückt.
Wie viel Treffe geht denn da durch? Was ist denn da so die verfügbare Bandbreite, wenn man dann wirklich mehr als nur Revolutionsbesteck sich zurechtlegen möchte?
Ja, also es kommt halt drauf an, wie groß sind die Linkstrecken, welche Entfernungen überbrücken die. Es bewegt sich irgendwo im ein- zweistelligen Ambit-Bereich.
Na gut, zum Nachrichtenklicken reicht das schon noch.
Ja, es reicht sogar. Wir haben hier ganz nett gebastelt. Es gibt eine Reihe Amateur-Funk-Relais, also Sprachstationen, die halt miteinander vernetzt sind. Also wenn ich hier in Osnabrück mein Handfunkgerät auspacke, dann kann ich mich in Damme, in Herford, wo stehen die eigentlich noch? Ich weiß es gerade gar nicht auswendig. Kann ich hier auf dem Relais sprechen und komme woanders wieder raus. Dann sind wir halt auch über das Hemdnetz vernetzt.
Also das funktioniert ganz gut.
Da steht dann hier in der Uni ein Steuerrechner, der dann die Amateur-Funk-Station koordiniert. Wo wird gerade empfangen, wo geht es gerade raus. Und so ein bisschen mehr Spielerei dazu, was man dann noch so braucht. Also es funktioniert schon ganz gut. Ja, danke auch.
Weiße Ostern, endlich mal.
Endlich mal weiße Ostern, ja.
Cool, da kann man seine grauen Brauneier verstecken.
Genau, Tarn-Eier in weiß.
Wo waren wir vorher?
Ich wollte auch gefragt, wo kamen wir eigentlich her?
Ich weiß es nicht mehr. Ich hab nur auf meiner Liste irgendwie noch Natt und UPnP stehen und wusste gerade nicht, in welchem Kontext wir das erzählen wollten. Ach so, na das geht vor.
Das Natt ist irgendwie keine Sicherheit und neue Geräte, die dieses UPnP-Protokoll sprechen, können sich durch dieses Natt Löcher schießen, dass sie von außen erreichbar sind. Das klappt inzwischen auch bei V4, dass Geräte von außen erreichbar sind und man da keinen großen Überblick drüber hat.
Natt dient ja quasi als Firewall. Der Router hat eine öffentliche IP-Adresse von dem Internet-Service-Provider und dahinter ist dann ein Netz wie 192.6.1 und so. Und man kann ein Port-Forwarding machen, damit die Rechner in dem Laden, also im Heimnetz von außen erreichbar sind. Und UPnP ist dafür da, dass Software das selber machen kann. Also dass ohne, dass man es merkt, bestimmte Ports und Rechner von außen erreichbar sind. Das ist natürlich ein großes Sicherheitsloch.
Aber es ist so, wie du wollt. Wenn du eine Bit-Torrent machen willst, dann ist ja so, dass du willst, dass auf deinem Rechner auch dieser Bit-Torrent-Klein von außen erreichbar ist, weil wenn alle nur sich nach außen verbinden können, aber keiner Verbindung annehmen kann, dann wär natürlich voll doof. Da würde man die ganzen P2P-Netze nicht hinbekommen. Das war dann auch der ganz große Boost für UPnP gewesen, als alle meinten, geht mein Bit-Torrent nicht. Dann gibt es dieses Protokoll, mach mal, geht nicht, dann brauchst du dir den Router und dann nehm ich den.
Oder Sprache über Internet-Protokoll.
Was ist das denn? Dazu gibt es auch diese Wählscheiben-Dinger?
Dazu nehm ich UPnP.
Na ja, das kann dir ja helfen, weil wenn du so was wie Zip sprichst, da gab es vorher die Unsitte, dass auf diesen Plast-Rutern so Application Layer Gateway nennt sich das. Das heißt, deine Zip-Anfrage wird umgebastelt in beide Richtungen. Also sowohl wenn sie aus dem Internet kommt, wird sie für dich umgebastelt, als auch wenn du sie Richtung Internet schickst, damit du hinter dem Nat erreichbar bist. Was natürlich nie funktioniert, weil das so räudiges Zeug ist, dass irgendwie, also, und deswegen, ja, halt UPnP, dass man sich die Ports durchreichen kann, unter denen man dann erreichbar ist.
Das Toll an der Lösung ist aber, dass du nur ein einziges Telefon in deinem Heimnetzwerk haben kannst, weil es nur einen Port gibt, welcher dann weitergeleitet wird. Also du kannst nur ein einziges Gerät dann verfügbar machen für eingehende Anrufe. Alle anderen Telefone können dann nur noch raustelefonieren.
Das ist doch räudiger Unfug. Erst diese Application Layer, Gateway, Müll und jetzt diesen, also... Wie gesagt, das wird sich nie durchsetzen. Das wird sich nie durchsetzen, diese Sprache über Internet. Geht's jetzt los?
Zum Ende der Sendung geht's los.
Komm, hau rein.
Echt?
Go, go, go!
Nee, überhaupt früher ist der Ende. Das war Peak Telefonie, weißt du? Danach war es vorbei. So, wenn der letzte...
Die Peak Telefonie, das verstehe ich jetzt nicht. Du meinst so im Sinne von...
Da waren noch Ingenieure am Start. Die haben es mir doch Mühe gegeben, haben sich Protokolle ausgedacht, die funktioniert haben. Dann kamen diese...
Weißt du, dass du eine isochrone Datenverbindung gehabt hast, wo du deine Datagrams reingeschoben hast und auf der anderen Seite kamen sie in der richtigen Reihenfolge im selben Takt wieder raus, da saß so was wie Musiktaxi, weißt du? So ISD-Inleitung, um Radio drüber zu schieben mit MPEG-Kodek. Und ich sagte ja, wenn das letzte Musiktaxi desynchronisiert, das allerletzte Fax stottert und überhaupt dann werdet ihr merken, dass man über IP nicht telefonieren kann.
Aber das Telefon ist ruhiger.
Es funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut mit diesem IP-Telefonieren. Also ich hab da jetzt bisher...
Da bist alle deine Nachbarn auch noch bitter und machen wollen und du dann...
Dann ist Schluss.
Ja.
Er sagt, du hast noch ne Minute Zeit, komm! Ich mein, Nibbler...
Nibbler hält sich gerade den Mund zu.
Ich verstehe aber nicht warum.
Er läuft ein bisschen rot an.
Ja, weil er sich den Mund zuhält.
Ja, weil die Lösung dafür ist, da dann einfach zu shapen. Rein zu gucken, was machen die Leute da eigentlich? Und sich dann dementsprechend die Verbindung aussuchen, die man den Benutzern da erlaubt, in voller Geschwindigkeit durchzuführen und mit wenig Latenz und das ist ja dann schon der Anfang vom Ende, wo so mit DPI nachgeguckt wird, was dürfen denn unsere Kunden da und der ISP sich dann aussucht? Und wenn er da erstmal so weit ist, dann fängt er auch an, wie die Telekom jetzt da mit diesem Testballon zu sagen, ja und ab so und so viel verbrauchter Traffic, die Bandbreite irgendwie auf halb DSL zurückgefahren. Aber ja, unsere tollen Angebote da aus unserer Mediathek, die kannst du weiter benutzen. Und dann ist glaube ich das Ende der Netzneutralität irgendwie schneller erreicht, als man sich das gedacht hätte.
Aber ISDN ist tot, oder?
Ist Facebook jetzt aus, oder?
Ja, die Telekom ist los werden, weil sie für ihre EVSD ist, also ihr elektronisches Wehrsystem digital oder die S12 von, also eines von sieben, das andere von Alcatel, keine Hardware mehr bekommen und keinen Support. Das ist so ein bisschen wie die Concord. Ist zwar eigentlich geiler Scheiß, aber ja, ist halt, wenn man halt und, ja, geht halt immer mehr hin dazu, dass du halt nicht nur deinen Internetanschluss hast, sondern dass über diesen Breitbandanschluss, die auch alle möglichen anderen Dienste feilgeboten werden, und dass es scheinbar günstiger ist, dann dann WIP zu deployen, weil, ja, ist günstiger und für das eine Prozent, was dann Probleme damit hat, weil bestimmte Dienste nicht mehr funktionieren, die haben dann halt Pech gehabt.
Das war Chaosradio 188. Es ging um Router. Im Studio waren Nibbler, Mirko und Erdgeist. Und der Nibbler hat sich zum Schluss noch ein Lied ausgesucht. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, dass du das jetzt anmoderierst. Aber nee.
Es handelt sich um Mavaren. Was machst du da?
Warum bist du gerade zu mir gekommen? Was ist denn da los? Ist das... Frechheit! Was hören wir jetzt, Nibbler?
Musik. Mavaren, Mancini, The Pink Panther Theme. In einem schicken Remix.
Chaosradio 189 am letzten Donnerstag im April auf allen Frequenzen von Fritz. Tschüss und danke für die Aufmerksamkeit.